all right and we are live the last word
with lor cognito ibontes thai guy travis
thursday evening
non-twib
edition
of the podcast
but we've got it also special guest that
we will introduce soon but first
how we doing e how we feeling
been good it's been a busy weekend
haven't made as many videos but been
playing the uh fun thing we're going to
talk about
like
yeah we'll talk about all of our
experiences we all played a ton
um just been absolutely blown away with
what they've done with this expansion so
far
and we'll kind of dive deep into that so
before we go too far though but yeah
that's mostly what i've been doing
nothing but
this and hopefully if i can get destiny
to a point of a little more kind of
maintenance i'm gonna do that full on
high dive into elden ring and i'm just i
haven't touched it yet i did install it
but i haven't touched it yet so that is
that's kind of the goal is to get it in
kind of a little more maintenance get a
couple videos like in the you know
actually uploaded and prepped and then
kind of
take a strong weekend and go like such
true power ibontis yeah i'm pretty
impressed
i had the same plan i was like i'm
reviewing destiny witch queen so i can't
i can't play it and i i lasted like
five hours i think the game had been out
for five hours before i started a
character so
yeah you got willpower dude yeah i know
that's killing them i just know if i
don't it's going to be a problem of i'm
not going to want to stop playing also i
want to stream it and
just been kind of balancing everything
so yeah travis what have you been doing
now you just got done literally
reviewing witch queens so yeah yeah my
review went live tried to help with that
yeah yeah you uh helped me get through
the part of the ride um yeah it was it
was quite a ride man i mean uh destiny
had been out for two weeks before my
review went live so it was basically a
full two weeks of me playing destiny
every day um and uh getting getting it
in i i
i liked it man it was a lot of fun you
can read my review on ign.com right now
and uh watch the video version on
youtube um i gave it an 8 out of 10
spoilers but uh there you go
that's the highest i've ever given a
destiny review just to be clear
so that's a pretty big uh pretty big
thing for me uh destiny has has had a
history a long history of uh sixes and
sevens um with me so i'm happy to have
finally gotten there um and you know
what if we were still on the 100 point
system at ign it probably would have
been an 8.9 to be honest with you i was
very close
i was very close i was very close to
giving it a nine but i just couldn't get
there
the issues with uh with crucible and um
and gambit and also strikes i still
think strikes aren't in a particularly
good uh just i feel like there's more
things they could add to that list just
so anytime you go to vanguard ops it's
like
it could be empire hunts it could be
nightmare hunts now we do have
battlegrounds in there that's like
psyops battlegrounds need to go in there
like that playlist could have 20
different things and you never know
and the fact that we lost so many
strikes i'm with you like yeah strikes
gimmick the playlists need some love
still but you know what we got in the
expansion
yeah it's like for me it's it's a nine
so that's like it's not the full
masterpiece like well then i'll go play
horizon elden ring and be like okay
those are damn good but yeah for me for
destiny especially but for me it was
still just like what i've been playing
i've been nothing but having fun
tweaks and stuff currency limits yeah
there's there's some imperfections
though
yeah
what about you what you been up to
before we continue oh i just want to
make sure that uh a great guest can hear
the amazing traverse because i don't
think she could hear him
so i just want to make sure yeah we
heard you fine but i just want to make
sure you know that uh our amazing guests
can you yeah yeah
yeah as soon as he started talking i got
the discord loading screen for oh
discord loading yeah so we gotta work
the technical can you shoot out maybe
when someone should leave come back or
how you wanna if you guys wanna both
leave and come back maybe that'll do it
okay there because you got to make sure
everything's hot
all right all right check one
there's one he's back two
all right all right travis you want to
say something hello can you hear me
there he is hey all right okay perfect
technical technical issues now back to
what i was playing
so yeah two weeks it's been two weeks
it's been the grind it's been it's been
it's been everything you know this
game's been everything and you know we
did the raid and
i've experienced
a lot of pain of contest mode but we
will get into it but uh look it's a
phenomenal expansion and i just can't
wait to talk about it even more but uh
we got a special guest here we got we
got someone that we gotta introduce
right indeed
sorry i was seeing like
last time i had this weird little like
memory leak thing going on and i want to
make sure it doesn't continue yeah
all right i'll blow v8 some more so um
anyway
so you love that word lately i love it i
love it i love it look it's been great
shout out to the clan everybody's been
rocking and rolling you know um i i have
my thoughts on the hierarchy now it's
it's getting to settle a bit but as far
as the expansion i'm with draft it is
this is
this is premium bungee campaign and the
raid did deliver you know um well we'll
get into hierarchy because i got
thoughts you know obviously you guys
have beaten it so you have more thoughts
from what i've seen
there's a lot to discuss but from a
narrative perspective
whoa
a lot yeah a lot to digest here so
e is that enough time for your house
how's our memory leaks how we doing
should be better hopefully if it plays
nice
okay i just may not see chat but that's
probably totally fine no
all right i'll help out in the chat yeah
you guys just helped me with chat i'll
figure that one out
it's just doing that thing where you
guys are blurry and then last time it
was this weird memory leak and like
it's just like freaking out right now so
is it discord or is it the uh what you
call it no it's multiple things i love
these technical difficulties by the way
sorry
i apologize to our guests when things
happen like runs totally smooth and then
no
good you good
we will get through shout out to patrick
s welcome to the channel supporter no
doubt salute to you
no doubt chat he's not what look he's
trying he's trying his life going on
yeah i'm trying to do that and keep the
podcast still running which is always
exactly part
see oh this is the joys of hosting that
people don't realize yeah things go
wrong and you're like cool yep not cool
got it
always fun
okay we're gonna roll with it i will try
not to get freaked out by what happens
if for some reason things crash out
audio could be a little funky in the
middle but nina you can hear him correct
you can hear travis yeah i can hear
everyone great now yes also let me bring
you into the campfire
welcome to the last word episode number
188
as we all rode the darkness taxi through
the throne world swamp we didn't know
that we were about to experience one of
the best raids of all time in the
franchise of destiny and who better to
join us tonight to discuss the darkness
pyramid and all things inside of it but
someone who spent 39 hours immersed in
the depths of the darkness
our guest tonight started her journey of
gaming before a controller even fit in
her hand with some classics like mario
zelda and crash bandicoot but things
actually got serious when she first
experienced final fantasy 7 on
playstation 1.
gaming turned addiction the first time
she played final fantasy 8 but if a game
has an engaging story deep lore and epic
moments she is there inter destiny
hunter is the master race in this lady's
eyes and she has the crucible numbers to
prove it but she's not only a pvp guru
and excels at high level content she is
a huge lore aficionado as well with
countless trips to the lighthouse and
plenty of raid sherpas she really is a
master of all things destiny but does
her excellent stop there no
she has helped raise over 20 thousand
dollars through her charity streams has
taught the art of bartending with bottle
flipping flair and is also skilled with
all things board sports both in liquid
and frozen water forms
so let's welcome a disappointed as
always cowboys fan
has to be a fan of star wars by gifts on
her timeline
admin of clan archive twitch partner and
owner of the newest glaive in destiny
the one the only last lady legend miss
nina how are you doing tonight
that amazing introduction thank you so
much oh you're welcome i try to hide
that cowboys fan thing in the off season
i don't know how you found that
we did it
[Laughter]
i don't wear my you know armor all year
long so it's hard to be a cowboys fan
look glad to have you you know um i love
the history i love the the gaming stuff
i want to kind of get into that
initially you know we share some uh some
things there you know you know one
particular was your just your
passion for final fantasy and how that
kind of got you into the playstation
ecosystem and it's kind of similar to
mine so if you could talk about that
briefly just like was it more of the uh
you know the storytelling the cinematic
nature of it like what kind of grasped
you into it like okay this is a game i
need to play
yeah so it was a little bit of all the
above there um you know i'm a 90s kid so
you know i was pretty young for the
final fantasy vii but it was just that
first game to give me that
that like blown away feeling um
i didn't you know have every game
growing up or every console or anything
like that we had a lot of stuff that was
kind of passed down from older cousins
and stuff so by the time it hit me it
was you know we'd probably come from uh
you know mario games and crash bandicoot
and other things like that that were
much simpler
and then to see the complexity of this
game it just
yeah i i still talk about that game like
it's just amazing
yeah yeah for me it was
i know it was different when i first
used a summon materia
and i was like what is happening
like it was just this grandiose titan
thing come take over your screen and
like demolish the enemy i'm like what is
happening how are they alive after i
just did what i did today
but i know what you mean it's definitely
a lot of people say that for um
especially the playstation playstation
one era i guess kind of like the one of
the first like mainstream jrpgs that
kind of resonated with everyone but then
you went on to eight right you continued
right
yeah so i was a couple years older now
you know so i i could understand i guess
the
the customization of the characters and
your loadouts and all that a little bit
more now
so um i remember the game was forward
disc for the for the playstation one and
uh oh yeah i must have burned through at
least three copies of it i've played
that game so many times just burning
through the story over and over again i
i absolutely
love the cinematics that blended in
and the storytelling
and the depth of the characters and
i hope they remake that one too nice
it's classic but you got e and trav for
our guest
no it's like i mean the gaming history
is big and the fact that you were like
kind of got
almost not like
you got to inherit gaming from people
who are already doing it so you're kind
of looking over the shoulder and
watching and getting to dab a little bit
before you're almost you know
not quite big enough to even hold the
controller as you said but like when you
get into that first game the first time
it really is something special for you
so the fact that it was like final
fantasy 8 is you got a pretty epic bar
to start off with which is really really
cool and then seven is still special and
you got to see one of them remade the
one that i'm waiting for from square
personally is chrono trigger so if i can
get my remake like 20 years down the
road cool but that'll probably never
happen because
that was like the co-mingling of a lot
of cool minds and
probably not gonna happen so
i won't hold my breath too much but um
no i wanted to ask you
how
did you actually transfer from you know
you've enjoyed adventure games and
single player these like cool moments
that you've experienced on your own
when you got into the world of destiny
like what was it like getting into that
and what was
you know has there many moments here
like i can't believe i'm still playing
this crazy game because i love stories
in destiny's bonkers on story or what
moments have kept you in it per se
um well when i started destiny you know
i
i wasn't gaming a lot at that time
pretty much at all you know i'd uh
graduated college and i was starting the
work grind and all that and i was
working two jobs so it was um a solo
kind of thing for me
i would sign on and just you know do
bounties and
i was content like you know and
just kind of explore around um
and then uh picking up
uh i think it was like the dead ghosts
in d1 that gave you the little grimmar
cards and you started to get into the
lore
and
i right away went to youtube you know
found some creators and i got sucked
into the lore videos i was like oh my
god there's so much more like i don't
even i thought i'd played this game and
there's so much more i don't understand
at all so and i haven't experienced that
so
it like set off this hunt in me to go
find more of the story
nice awesome nice
nice
so if you're a lore person
my question is
there's a lot of new lore that has
popped up in the past couple weeks
especially with the release of the raid
we got a few bombshells
uh you know one a couple i noticed was
uh
the
origins of the worm that's inside the
pyramid ship that we see and some of the
others yeah
what um what new lore has you most
excited and why
um i think it's uh i'm not sure what the
official name is the prophecy wall i
think i've seen it called a couple times
right and
a lot of times when you go through the
raid only one image is there but people
have pieced together
all the images so far and it's telling
the story of
possibly what's going to happen in late
fall
so i've been following a lot of threads
on that and started you know
once again watching the videos and
getting a lot of other inputs and
you know commenting and kind of sparking
some questions there and
it's uh i mean i don't know how much
spoilers we're giving away but uh
i was [ __ ] excited so yeah i was like
not a spoiler if it's in the game right
now yeah so i would say at this point
like if you haven't dove into the raid
haven't played the game in about four or
five days we are gonna go deep on
raid encounters thoughts and all of that
stuff so if you're trying to do the raid
blind for any reason and haven't looked
at it yet fy that stuff is coming so
this is your time to check out and
bookmark this podcast for later uh that
being said yeah spoilers are pretty much
on the table at this point for all of it
because that's part of why we're here we
spent all these hours inside this thing
we're going to talk about it pretty in
depth
so
um
well nina it is very good to have you
here uh i think you may have actually
spent the most hours within the raid
betw before ahead of all of us i was
i was probably close to 24 in there i
think between the couple days that i
grinded but i think you were did you
sleep at all like what was your
what was your rate experience like to be
honest i'm curious like did you start
because i know the hours so i'm kind of
curious what was your rate experience
like so let us know how this thing went
down
uh so we jumped in right at the start
you know um i have a
great friend group that we've read in
you know the past few years and a lot of
them are in my clan now um
and
you know we've been talking about this
preparing for this for a couple weeks
uh we even went back and three manned a
few raids did some you know fun
activities like that yeah get the skills
out
[Laughter]
we we jumped in write a drop and we were
met immediately one of those teams to
get error coded and [ __ ] out
i think maybe three or four times in the
first encounter so
which should have been a quick
run-through
took us over an hour
maybe an hour and a half wow
yep we were one of those so i'm lucky um
wow we are very lucky that
the horror stories i'm hearing from so
many people i have we have one and
that's that we were lucky the fact that
we only had one
mine was worse than hers mine was we
were getting booted for five or six
hours like damn it was like a while and
not only that but we got booted after
completing that opening part a couple
times and then before starting the first
encounter so we had to redo that whole
intro where you're riding the ship all
the way to the thing you know
a couple times and then once we actually
got into the first encounter it was
constantly
uh especially on runs were that were
going well we'd finally have things
going well and then all of a sudden a dc
would happen and we'd all get booted
orbit and then we also had that issue i
don't know if you had this nina where uh
the rally banners weren't working like
you'd put them down and you couldn't
rally them and you'd have to wait like
five ten minutes to do it it got so bad
that we were just like all right we're
gonna go to orbit and then come back and
then put the rally banner down after
every wipe which made it take even
longer so
my situation was like
six hours into it when the when the
issues finally stopped our team was
super demoralized yeah like
already at the point where we were like
you know exhausted and from from we
hadn't even done the first encounter
hadn't even really had a shot at the
first encounter by that point
so
yeah it was a very demoralizing day
back to back to you
yeah
no no i definitely you know we felt a
lot of those bugs throughout the raid so
you know we felt that kind of beat down
feeling sometimes you know too um
but uh yeah we were able to get through
um
the first encounter and then second
counter
um i want to say you know we were there
for a couple hours
we did have some rally the flag errors
um
and some i occasionally like i don't
know if this was just maybe connections
between us but de-syncing because of the
shooting of the crux to open the doors
sometimes like doors weren't opening
this is horrible so yeah um but we you
know we were
we were still very committed and stuck
with it and you know we we kept morale
high and uh
kept the discussion up you know yeah um
yeah so we just kept talking and you
know
everybody was just you know we were
figuring out encounters by ourselves as
we were going um
and we just you know just kept
spitfiring and
we figured it out and you know
progressed pretty quickly you know and i
think the unstoppable came out and
scared us a little bit
i kind of like how they you know they
went back to tougher enemies not just
you know
like the yellow bars are actually a
little tougher and a little more aggroed
on you you know that gives me a little
bit more of a d1 vibe for encounters
yeah uh
but yeah it was it was fun you know a
little chaotic and
i think i think it was a couple hours we
got through
uh the second encounter so
nice nice
yeah so so he's interested to hear
because it's like
you know
my art experience was like really clean
and then it was like a shock to me to
hear so many people say exactly what you
said you know dc's and what travis was
saying and and obviously you said you
had you know some issues with that as
well
i wanted to talk to you about once you
went past obviously did the first week
we got a little taxi as he calls that
you're going in you know what i mean and
then you get into
the actual parts with the totems and the
obelisk like how was that with your team
constructed and like figuring that part
out like how was that for your team
that was you know we kind of did like
the i guess the like survey and take
notes approach first so you know we
split up covered the room looked at
everything you know
um
we really kept chatter high up so you
know as we restarted the encounter a few
times we we saw the pattern happening
right away so
we were you know able to kind of dissect
and figure it out pretty quick who found
it taken first
we'll find them sneaky taken who who
first
like speaking of the taken was the one
as you enter the room
because we had we were like hey we have
three locations over here we have three
locations over here and the people by
the front entrance we're like we've
really only got two spots and then for
the longest time we're going
where's the compass guys and they
finally like oh that might be ours so
they finally found their third spot so
that was a fun little moment but after
that yeah
anyway yeah i don't know who found it
first but um
i want to say it was uh
my clan mates mads million and aaron
that uh
kind of figured it out like right away
like okay we kill him quick and then the
next symbol comes and you know and then
the next one's spawning right away too
so
we uh
we just kept moving you know just we we
kind of took a like third encounter of
deep stone crypt like just okay yes
okay
we all went in with uh
void builds volatile builds so you know
are you trying to focus hard on addclear
nice
what about the scroll with the shields
girl what about them sean they were
getting on my nerves the ones that would
come up with this [ __ ] and that and then
what you know what pissed me off i got a
sidebar i've been around here i supposed
is why their animation is faster than
the other ads and then they
rush to the obelisk and then they shoot
me just to speed up the i didn't like
those guys those are the guys that were
debating my it wasn't it wasn't the
unstoppable
it wasn't to take it it's those two
scoring with the shield the shields are
very effective i will tell you that
fusion rifles to their knees takes them
out pretty quick so mommy that's what i
was doing too already there's actually a
couple yellow bart screams that caught
me off guard too yeah one with the tooth
yeah i think they just
crushed it
yeah he come with the gang though he
come with a convoy i know that one you
talk about so here's the question for
this encounter this is the first time
we're seeing
all of these new symbols that we've got
oh my god so i got to know some of the
best call outs goofy call outs what did
you guys because i want to go through
for everybody first time you saw these
symbols people tended to like hey some
were similar but what are some of the
fun ones you guys had or so what some
when you actually saw what everybody was
doing later what is some that was like
way off i got to know people's callouts
so that's right maybe your let me know
some fun ones hello can you call me
because you know mine are going to be
insane
afternoon it's going to be hilarious
okay ah let's see i mean yeah there's
the obvious ones that we saw the you
know the pyramid and the traveler yeah
oh my god uh it was
what was some fun ones we had
[Music]
i think somebody was calling like the
red hands one to give like death hands
okay yeah i've heard that um let's see
yeah uh i even may have said that we
didn't stick with that we did something
totally different
we didn't pizza slice on that one we did
pizza
yeah it's like this little triangle
um
i don't i i thought we were the only
ones calling enter teardrop but then we
said teardrop yeah
okay so yeah yep we did teardrops
um
this one wasn't mine this was this is
another friends and he's still kind of
like dying on this hill he calls the the
commune the green prism monochromatic
pink floyd we said green floyd
we said green fluids and that one we
could we can't do commute com commune
it's like green floyd so
let's see and then i think cuphead but
that was kind of popular okay yeah
very powerful i like that yep
but uh i think a friend had
uh found like already at this point
because it was like three hours in so
somebody had made like
you know
here's universal call-outs kind of thing
and yeah they actually didn't make it
bungie gave us canon names this time you
can find them out by going to the
amazing room yeah they they actually
have names all of them
uh yeah that list that's going around
like drink and enter and uh witness
they're all like the actual names of
these symbols i need i need to clear it
somebody get me
here's the thing about the the canon
names though unless everybody takes time
to do it they're actually not super
useful because some of them don't really
look that much like what yeah and so
it's actually easier for you to come up
with your own that like you're gonna
immediately recognize like if teardrop
works for you guys everybody's gonna
look at that and go that's a teardrop no
one's gonna go oh that one's enter
because it looks like a door you know
what i mean like
some of them are just a little more
abstract so i think um yeah like green
floyd may i'm not going to remember
reflection i'm going to like say floyd
and it looks like the pink floyd symbol
but green i'm going to be like yup know
what that is i'm not going to remember
that reflection green floyd is sticking
with our team i'm pretty sure that one
sticks
do you have anything travis do you have
any goofy ones yeah so my role on a raid
group when we do day one raids is
uh to keep everybody in a light mood
because day one raids can be contentious
and can result in in fighting and so oh
yeah my my job is to just make everybody
laugh and so
i came up with my own call-outs that
were deeply personal to my own life
as a joke as as a joke wow as a joke
this is going somewhere the one with the
hole in her chest was called my
childhood oh my gosh
the one with the uh with the guy that
was worshiping the other dude that one i
called that one my relationship to my
father
and so
this has the
they started to call them by some of my
names they were like oh travis's dad
would be like
um so yeah it was good we had a lot of a
lot of fun with the symbols and i
intentionally called them things that
were incredibly hard to remember and
people would kind of get a little
frustrated but then they'd laugh they
just it kind of kept the the mood light
during that yeah you got to
um yeah i had a lot of fun with that one
yeah yeah i don't really have much to
compete with that i think
something was like chicken fingers or
something they call one of them with the
hair hands yeah the hands is probably
one of those because i've seen like some
person said it was like two people we
were going to pizza like i've seen like
devil hands is what i said at one point
two hands that's one of the ones that
i've seen the most
confused about because some of them make
sense some of them you can interpret
like
clover we call love which is
i've seen that one out there um
grief it's called love yeah in the canon
in the game yeah wait which one's called
love the ones the pink ones the pink
ones
yeah we called that like swirl or
pinwheel or something at one point i
think before that one is actually the
only one we got right uh well no a few
of them you got right because everybody
got pyramid and stuff like that yeah the
hands one is actually called gift and we
we called it gift organically because it
just it looked like somebody was giving
you something yeah we were like
and then we found out later that that's
what it was actually called well i'm
gonna we're gonna stick with brain i'm
pretty we either we call it a big brain
but yeah that's definitely gonna be
brain and not knowledge
uh but the grief one with the big circle
in the chest we call that iron man and i
think that stays okay
okay um i'm trying to think what else
kill we had like steak through the like
steak for the heart
i don't think there was anything but
yeah it was like the pizza
brains
most like a lot of them were there we
had the witness like worship or praise
the light or whatever the dark souls
thing is like the that was kind of one
that we were using as well but overall
you got any goofy ones cog
i think just that that chicken fingers
one hole in heart
cuphead
um
i'm trying to think other than they were
just saying someone should say savathone
yeah because some people were saying
that for the high face and some of them
were yeah that's confusing yeah
confusing yeah you know what i really
liked about this raid when we were
figuring out the symbols is how much it
was a rorschach test for the community
because certain people saw certain
things in it that just they cracked me
up i was just like i don't know how you
see that right how did you see that when
you did yeah it was just so funny um
the rate i i love i liked this one a lot
better than the symbols from last wish
because the last wish ones were
like sort of practical first of all they
didn't have canon names but this one i
felt like when i was learning the
symbols i it was also trying to tell me
a story yeah what's going on
characters and things that were relevant
to the game rather than just like a
random bird that had
everything yeah birds dragons fish
infinity snake i'm like
yeah yeah i just take it yeah it didn't
it didn't feel like destiny this one
felt like you the symbols were all
destiny related like oh like i'm
learning like a story here like there's
pieces yeah it's like destiny hybrid
glyphics and you're like oh i can get on
board with this yeah i felt yeah it's
definitely an evolution i i got to give
leviathan a little credit because i felt
like it was relevant to
cabal or like yeah cup and dog and
whatever but this was definitely
like the best storytelling version
of symbols by far like you you felt like
you were learning something and then
again with the motif for the whole
like i feel like you're in a museum and
it's a collection going on and you know
the whole rock thing so i i do agree to
travel like i definitely felt like it
was relevant you know i'm saying
everything that was going on in
reference to the symbols even though
there was a lot of
he taught me the uh the hole in heart
one he called it iron man which i didn't
think of and that was very funny yeah
i liked that call out a lot i like that
oh
y'all there was a couple that were tough
that were like ascendant plane or yeah
plane yeah we thought that like i don't
think they got us end up playing we
called it throne world or something we i
think they actually got to send a plan
before we had the official maybe or they
looked that one up i was thinking like
it was like a mirror fountain or
something is kind of what i had said at
one point but i think the senate plane
actually kind of got in there and stuck
overall yeah we'll get to the twelve a
little bit later but we do at least have
a twap now so that's good
yeah that's that encounter
all in all like it took a little while
to figure out but that was kind of that
was the first time we saw these symbols
i saw the little signposts going in and
i was like huh wonder what that thing's
for and we figure out now it's for the
like the red outline weapon at the end
which you do but yes but yeah have i
will say i don't know of a whole lot of
titans that made that first jump without
dying
because like hunters you guys can stop
in midair warlocks you guys can stop in
midair but titan trying to slow that
much velocity down i have started i've
stopped like halfway and
even when it finally goes like bank it
still nearly kills me
so
we thought at first when we were doing
that drop down just to get down there
we're like okay we here don't die on the
way down and we are like all right
everybody don't die death death death
we didn't glitch out thank goodness but
yeah that was that was interesting but i
will say like that encounter the first
time we got in there and kind of looked
around because we were looking around
trying to figure it out
after that encounter
like when you actually before we get to
that because that was actually hilarious
travis will kind of explain the horse of
many butts
uh oh yeah
when you guys did you get any guns first
or just armor the first time you guys
saw a gun what did you guys think for
one any cool perks but two just a look
like obviously they have that very
special rotating barrel to them i wanted
to see like first time you guys saw a
gun you're like
thoughts on those so nina like what was
your first loot or first time you saw a
gun from the raid what was kind of your
reaction and feel yay nay like the
aesthetic
i do actually i've i've always liked the
destiny
gun
aesthetics like you know every armor and
every gun might not be your favorite but
i love the original themes and how
different they are
um i think the first gun i got was the
submachine gun nice yeah me too me too
same one yeah yeah and you know i was
checking it out right away i was like i
love this like you know kind of look
like the adjudicator a little bit vibe
for me from year one and
you know i i was all about it i didn't
get a great role so i didn't try it
during the raid you know we just kind of
continued with what we had
yeah but i you know i was like
lock this i'm saving this for later you
know like
um
i do feel like now that i've played a
couple times and gotten a couple more
like i've gotten the pulse i feel like
it looks a little clunky
like
the back end look a little hefty
exactly i don't have the gold that's the
one i want oh my god it's so good
it's a go figure it's a four shot pulse
i know exactly why i want it i can't get
it and i've had
seven i've had so many linear fusion
rifles regular fusion rifles
i got a couple like one grenade launcher
a couple sub machine guns
zero pulses cannot get a pulse
yeah
i'm surprised with the armor the colors
that are on it naturally and like i
guess
you like them huh
it does seem to
i guess it's odd it's like if you look
at some of the pictographs or whatever
we've got i could kind of see one or two
of those it almost looks like the black
garden image kind of slapped on the
shader
but yeah i was like when i got it the
first time i was like oh
all right
i mean there are cool aesthetic pieces
to like some of it moves fair warning
there's like little
kind of
metal metal tendrils basically that will
kind of do this little slow waving
animation the hunter cloak i think is
the most obvious of those because it's
massive but they look like the uh
the creatures that come out of the
caretaker
yeah a little bit oh or the or the the
stranger's pet which i think did anybody
catch on to that i think that the
stranger's pet kind of looked like those
things
oh the fish
yeah yeah it's like a darkness fish
that's the same like i was like i forgot
that yeah yeah why did you get this on a
pyramid ship is this pyramid origin i
mean she's kind of embraced stasis and
darkness and who knows what else she's
done so that actually would make some
sense i hadn't thought about the fish in
a while i just was like i want i don't
know when we get to the boss i want
armor that looks like that dude
that's like we'll get there but yeah
when when you i guess that would have
been maybe a giveaway of what's coming
so maybe that's why they can't go quite
as hard into
armor that looks exactly like him but
generally it's yeah i would have liked
to seen a little more it just it threw
me when i'm going
red dark green and white so i'm like
nothing nothing in here is white
why are we seeing these colors it's very
strange we here at the warlock
delegation do not approve
this is not a goal this is that this is
a horrible radar i am sorry i was like
oh that that that i haven't seen what
the warlocks armor looks like oh my god
the face is doing the tingle the with
the tingle
i mean have you seen the hunter cloak
like
the hundreds of two feet taller
we are not happy i'm so glad i did not
get
any of that like everybody luckily
exactly
exactly bro it is awful you guys look
like a bionicle what's this stuff
it's unbelievable thank god i did not
get one armor piece uh i've been so
[ __ ] transmitted
every drop i've got has been
weapons it's been all weapons i've got
one piece all but i'm happy i'm happy
sorry i know you're going through it but
yeah i got you some [ __ ] yeah but
there's mods though you're gonna wish
you got it yeah there are one in them
i'm blocking the mods now but you still
need the right armor to put them on so
that's my point yeah so tell me tell me
about what what any some of the arm mods
do anybody know anybody got any good
mods or
i mean well it was i don't know if it
was bugged at first because i've now
played enough times that some of them
were starting to drop but when i got a
piece of armor say it was whatever
energy type it was you would go on it
and the mods were literally already
there and now as i've been unlocking
them and they're dropping i'm seeing
like duplicates so
somehow they managed to give all the
mods
straight away
and then i don't know if that's going to
be fixed later if it's already yeah
because i can go any armor piece i've
got has whatever mods there and i can
switch it to like ark solar void all the
mods are just there wow
yeah there's the biggest one especially
that helps with dps is
the higher if you have a certain like if
you have a you know several number of
stacks of the
darkness one that builds
you do more damage
oh so in theory especially for the final
fight which you haven't seen and other
things you do more damage in that state
so that's like a nice thing to add for
dps for like final pushes and stuff like
that so it's actually
it will have some benefits later on
because you can stack those too
so yeah you will want the armor
especially if you go hard difficulty but
also help some with dps so there are
some interesting ones
uh i can't remember all of them they're
looking at these armors and i'm i'm
amazed like the titans actually for once
have a really good argument compared to
other classes
sharpening thank you that is though that
is the most umbral sharpening do not
agree
you don't you don't like the titans look
i haven't got the whole set on yet i
actually thought like the because i got
the arms the legs
the helmet looks dope i don't think i
have the helmet i don't think i got the
helmet
it kind of makes you look like the uh
who's that knifey boy from soul calibur
you know yeah yeah voldemort
reminds me like if voldemort became a
titan that's kind of what he reminds me
of yep um
that's really cool yeah the arms and
legs are cool they don't move so i got
the two static pieces uh and then i
think i got the class item so i don't
have the fun ones yet but i mean i don't
know if you were asking
what you were asking about our response
to loot dropped the first thing that
happened was
i got the uh machine gun
and as i mentioned before we were
getting booted to orbit like a million
times during that encounter so we took a
breather uh when we finally beat it and
uh i immediately went to mars to see if
we could craft it
i wanted to see and i and you could and
i was i was super shocked i was like oh
my god so it is their whole i think all
the all of the stuff you get in the raid
is in the crafting table they're all in
there amazing
so um i'm going to be crafting that
pulse rifle yeah you bet like
oh yeah if i could get i gotta wait till
next week i've gone through everything
i've gone all three times this weekend
well zero pulls rifles out of five runs
even if you get the pulse rifle i've
gotten the pulse rifle twice and
uh neither of them would deep sea yeah
so it'll it'll work
oh you did damn you yeah you need five
you need five so it'll be yeah it's a
long journey
about minecraft
that's the only thing i got over you
guys you guys completed it you got five
i got let me have this
[Laughter]
when you're able to craft it in a month
from now when you get five you'll still
be ahead of them so don't yeah
i had a really cool looking uh linear
fusion rifle uh yeah really bad perks
the solar ones yeah i got back
but yeah i was i was stoked about that
but the sound of the trap the way it's
like i don't know it's like a nice feel
to it
yeah i feel to it i like it feels like
i'm shooting a star wars laser at
somebody it's amazing yes
so nina i gotta ask
once you finish that encounter with the
obelisks and the symbols and we have the
champions we've got all that done get
your loot walk through the door
you see the 12 asked horse twice
and then over the edge
[Music]
that was the moment so you got the horse
a couple times and you're like this is
weird travis you can explain why in a
second
but then i wanted to so he'll give out
tell us now why are the horses so many
butts
yeah so i i had the privilege of
discussing this on the iron lords
podcast but uh
the horses with many butts is a
reference to this phenomenon in
collapsed world cultures that
uh happens in like um
when when uh archaeologists dig up like
a site where uh especially with like
ancient rome and like those old
civilizations that
died in europe where they'll find these
like
weird
marble pieces of marble and stone that
have like statues half carved into them
and a lot of the stuff you see in his
museum pyramid looks exactly like that
stuff and you can see these rooms if you
go like a tour yeah like one of these
old places and
a lot of it is because uh artists that
were like carvers were practicing and so
they'd practice like heads so they do
like five heads on one piece of a block
just to practice it and then those
pieces end up getting found later and
they look super creepy because it's like
somebody practicing just heads and uh
you you can also they they you can also
find examples where they were practicing
animals and so there would just be like
a series of like centipede-like legs
where they were just practicing carving
legs and i've seen stuff in real life
that looks just like that so when i saw
it that combined with all the statues
that are like half built in the shape
and i was like i know exactly what
they're going for like this guy has like
pillaged old worlds and like collected
all the stuff that he left behind and so
you see all these like weird statues and
stuff that are parts of that world but
it's like it it super alludes to like
all the stuff that you can go and see if
you go like visit ancient rome and stuff
like that it's really love that stuff
the horses were uh i i believe i'm i'm
fully convinced for a reference to that
sort of like weird uh statue stuff you
can find in our real world which is
super awesome for a history nerd like
myself yeah like i didn't know via you
say that because yeah history is
especially like an excavation
ancient civilizations nerd so that spoke
to me and i was like i know what he's
doing you know what i'm saying it's like
you know it's just so cool it's like yo
these are all the worlds that fell
you know before and he has them like it
was just so dope i really got wrapped
into the lord there but it's cool that
you you realize the same thing with that
so nina like that up to that first
encounter we wrote a little text they
were like cool we're going into mirror
pyramid then we see some cool stuff as
we go through we're seeing some symbols
then we're doing the first encounter
after that encounter on that door opens
what moment for you
could have been the end could it be what
like visual moment just was kind of that
jaw-dropping pause or did you have any
of those moments where you're just like
what any wow moments basically in the
raid when you kind of really got past
that first encounter to see a lot like
what what did it for you in there or did
anything do it i should say i i think
like everybody we stopped and looked at
the worm like right away and we had that
discussion is it being you know siphoned
power from is it
you know willingly like powering like
that obelisk or you know
cylinder you see kind of in the
background there or
you know um is it a prisoner here like
oh you know oh my my uh raid group are
all kind of lower nerds together too so
we probably only took like a little 15
minute because we were taking it as like
a little wind down after that encounter
too but
we right away we're like you know just
like oh my god what is this is it that
is that like you know and like all these
ideas came to head you know and
we were just kind of like
taken back to you by like how expansive
it was you know
that's one of the things i've always
compared in d1 from d2 is you know the
the expansive backgrounds that they've
done so well in destiny 2. it's just
amazing
yeah like you see the red sky and you
see like the crackling of energy back
there and then you see the more pyramids
you know architecture and everything and
it was just like i don't know just so
many questions popped to mind you know
you're like i haven't i have questions
lots of them
we
yeah
and now we know the answer but yeah i
had that question yeah what is that
answer sir
since i know we know apparently
is apparently the mother of worms
exactly the other worms yeah which is
pretty crazy
yeah so this guy this guy has like
killed the gods that have been troubling
us they he killed their parents like
that i think that's supposed to be it's
supposed to put fear into you like wow
and and that moment was so cool by the
way and uh
i know you're always saying a car give
give him your roses i'll do the opposite
of that whatever the opposite of roses
is i'll take my licks on this one as
soon as we saw that somebody in our
group was like i bet you the final
encounter is going to happen in that
square above the worm and i turned to
him and i was like shut up you idiot
that thing's so far away
i was like you think we're actually
going to hike all the way over there
like
yeah i was like
don't be
dumb that was the best part it was just
like first time when you finally realize
when you get a little like perspective
on first time you went to the shattered
throne
you could see where you were going and
you finally get that little peek and
you're like we end up there and yeah as
i was checking the chat basically the
idea is that the boss will get to him a
little bit more later but basically that
worm
in the lore that you'll get later once
you beat it there's a mission and stuff
like that he basically made the hive
what they are he
fought the leviathan the big bone
the big gigantic
number just told me it was at the top
yeah so that's that is a rib
of the leviathan that was keeping the
worms
at bay on fundament
and then
big boy
basically took out the leviathan not a
whole lot of effort to it apparently it
sounded like it was pretty easy task for
him and then that's how the whole
process of the proto-hive becoming the
hive and the hive got
that'll happen because of this dude
that's crazy yeah so the fact that we
got that type of story was just i'm
loving how much story we're getting
yeah it was amazing the only question i
still haven't had answered in maybe a
year i haven't caught up in all the lore
yet i've been trying to because it's
just been there's so much so much um but
uh
maybe you know nina
i still don't really understand why the
disciple was in sabbath's throne world
and if he was like trapped there or like
what the deal was because this dude's
supposed to be like going out throughout
the galaxy doing the witnesses bidding
and it sounds like he got like trapped
in the throne world or something i don't
i still don't understand what was
happening there i forget the details
chat may help us a little bit with that
one do you know nina or have you guys
have you caught i actually was googling
that and to see if anybody made a video
or yeah
says they got you so they might fill it
in because i know
a couple of my chat actually go
way deeper on the raid uh
yep i figured it was going to be
something like that like she used her
trickery to get him there i don't know
why you would want him in there because
wasn't he hunting her for super long
but i think that might have been her way
uh he was sent there to watch sabathun
to make sure
uh i guess she became a disciple
so these sound like theories then if
we're getting multiple answers yeah okay
he's so powerful how does he get trapped
by her yeah i don't get that part either
yeah that's what there's like so many i
guess just pulls in this story still so
far you know yeah
for sure
it seems like it is now
post what we got are doing
i think so
yeah yeah he was watching to keep
savithoon in check for the witness and
then when she got the light maybe
so yeah there's definitely some idea he
was there for a purpose and then maybe
there was some trickery that he managed
to get trapped
but i mean that's part of the lore too
when you're going through
doesn't the ghost say there's this
entire darkness
city and sabathune either didn't know or
whatever
yeah he's
he's an interesting one
anyway we'll get to him a little bit
later because that was just kind of a
crazy reveal uh so we get to the second
part
and go through a little bit more we see
all the like the preservation museum
setup that you've got going on
and then you get to our boy quasimodo
[Laughter]
um so i wanted to ask you guys
when it came to that um
did you
how like first off were you did he
what did you guys think of a fight
because for me this is one of the first
times because i've been trying to
compare i've seen a lot of raid rankings
and we'll do that before we go so we'll
kind of tuck that at the end
but i've been thinking about encounters
that we've had previously the amount of
movement you have to do the way the
levels are shaped up and things like
that
and i have noticed
probably the most verticality especially
in this encounter
i would say cool the fact that you've
got different levels the animation of
the stairs coming down um different
teams kind of work in different pieces
but just the fact that how the the scale
of the room when you finally because we
explored it first and we're like people
were jumping around get we got to the
third floor before you we even started
the thing we were jumping around and
seeing everything
um i just kind of wanted to get you guys
taken how that that encounter was it
something you were pleasantly surprised
do you find it annoying what do you guys
think of the second counter and did it
you know if you didn't go exploring up
were you surprised when the stairs
dropped type thing so anybody can take
that
don't jump in oh yeah i'm sorry i gotta
try it you go jeff okay i was just gonna
say i loved this encounter from
beginning to end and i didn't even
bother me that i was on it for like
eight hours or however long it took us
to beat it um it it was
super cool i did not go exploring
upstairs so when the stairway came down
somebody said there's stairs and i went
oh no there's gonna be a scene change on
every floor and that like yeah that i
love that because it meant uh you never
got bored of the environment you know
because we got stuck on the second phase
for a while where we were on the second
floor and people were kind of learning
that and how to succeed there and then
the third one we didn't spend very long
before we beat it but yeah it was like
uh every every uh step that we got to
was exciting and the fact that the rooms
were different that the emblem uh
grabbers had to go into or like a
different situation every time so
um i really like the encounter i love
that the boss is a soft boy he looks big
but he doesn't really hit very hard and
he's kind of like just a he kind of he
kind of gives me like sad vibes you know
you get up right
you can get it right in his face and
punch him and he'll like hit you back
but he doesn't even take you to half
health he's just he just sort of he's
kind of just a sad guy he's not he's not
going for threatening he's just uh it's
like you're fighting a librarian
basically and he's very upset that
you're you're
ruining his day uh
yeah he could take a punch but he can't
really give one give one out you know
i like that a lot um
so yeah there were so many things about
it that were cool the premise i think is
is super cool the fact that you have to
juggle so many things at once and people
have to keep stunning him and all that i
thought that was really dope
it didn't take us very long to figure
out how to do the encounter at least
like the broad strokes because they do a
pretty good job of teaching you uh kind
of the principles earlier but it took us
a really long time to master it to like
have every part go exactly right and
then especially dps on contest mode like
that was
brutal okay i got you all right
so
yeah
but i really like that encounter i
thought it was uh a really good check
i'd be willing to bet that most people
didn't get past that encounter on day
one because that one was like really the
yeah i was like you can see the numbers
you can see the numbers of the drop off
yeah yeah if you didn't do if you can't
do dps like you're stuck on that
encounter so that was really cool i like
that one cog what about you man
yeah it's funny try what trap said is
how i felt too because it's like
as much as we struggled on it i didn't
get mad because i liked the encounter
and i thought for me okay what is he
doing why is he
not bothered by us and then once we
started interfering
he then started to chase it shout out to
forte was in the chat i want to shout
out to forte and sinister they are the
best harassers of this thing i've ever
seen like they had him bothered down
there and they kept the yeah they kept
their stun game going and he just would
not leave that bottom platform and uh we
did really good there the issue was um
obviously going inside getting your
symbols and as you progressively go up
you know it's a little bit more intense
for the person inside but i really like
the encounter i thought that um
it it broke the team up in a cool unique
way you know saying like all six had to
be doing something different and
again we had two down there
two add clear on each side of the room
and then you gotta be careful you can't
let those guys get down again those
vicious shield guy you know all the
snipers at the top doing a lot of damage
and stuff like that but as you go up the
verticality was just cool and i gotta
give bungie they slick
because what they did in this was
something very unique that i know they
probably did their research on they're
like okay we're gonna do plates but
you're not going to stand on this plate
here and just dps all day you're going
to move
and it was like well this is the power
is going to fade and then you got to
move to the second one
so the the person who's like me normally
i'm designated well duty right the well
duty guy got to make a decision all
right do we use on first place second
plate you know what we doing on third
plate then you got to try to get as much
dps in as much as possible and for
contest mode yeah it was rough but i
will say like it was
fun and then as you go up the steps come
down you go up to the next level it gets
more intense more intense so yes forte's
in there yeah salute yes your dps is on
point yes dj orals here defeated
i got my dps guys in here but um yeah
man it's a fun encounter it really was
we bit it beat it off of contest mode
and it was satisfied because i had to
pay him back for what he he terrorized
me on contest well he terrorized my team
but i love that it kind of i'm gonna
give it to you guys what what did you
think about it in general like how was
your your guys experience with it on
contest mode as well yeah nina i know
you spent what i'm kind of curious like
how many i know you had a lot of hours
in this thing uh what how much time did
you spend on this one what was your guys
experience like
um i i want to say it was overall
another few hours um
you know unfortunately we ran into some
bugs here
i'd say we figured out the mechanic you
know because we already know we got to
shoot the obelisk great so
we ran into that bug where you're just
shooting the obelisk and nothing's
happening a couple of times
yeah
so
unfortunately you know uh as we were you
know picking up momentum and getting the
rhythms down and
you know
you find the
you're in that perfect run where the dps
is great and the stuns were great and
then the obelisk would bug out so
we had a couple little like hiccups like
that but
probably you know another like with
discussions and you know
dps checks on the way like you know
analyzing the numbers and stuff like
that a few hours
we got we got uh we got lucky we were
what was your what was your load on this
one yeah
um i was actually the emblem collector
so i was i was on the runner so yeah so
i was a hunter so you know it was easy
to avoid the wizards one-shotting you
just to keep spamming invis and yeah you
guys have that you guys have that option
those those wizards hurt
those things
those things those little floaty shards
and you touch one you're like al dead
yeah
and uh i think on what the second level
the room layout for the emblems is
really not to your advantage
so i think it made hunter a little
easier so we didn't switch roles
everybody had their role you know and
their their pair and we just stuck with
it and
we felt progress you know so we stuck
with it and
we we moved through and it was it was
pretty good um
i i like the encounter i was ready when
we got to the second floor for a
mechanic change i thought something was
going to be different like okay we got
to stun him differently
or
he's going to move in a different
pattern or something or maybe the first
one was up close dps now we're going to
have to be range dps
you know and they and they did do little
different elements like that kind of not
a hard one but a little touches
at the top yeah i like how you said that
though and i think that's a good way to
describe this raid
at least for our experience it always
felt like we were making a little bit of
progress whether we failed
whether we you know stubbed your toe
with a glitch it was still
it got a little more polished the the
runners got a little bit smoother at
their call-outs and talking to each
other ads were a little bit more things
just kind of
got a little bit better
on a continual basis and i think it was
that little feeling of progression that
we continually had and again we were
lucky we didn't have that many issues
desyncs and stuff like that that we
definitely had and we'll cover that
towards the end but generally it was um
i think
just the continual feeling of baby steps
of progression
really helped as you said kind of keep
everybody calm keep everybody talking
and it really even if it was a long time
in there it was those moments that you
you had that incentive to keep pushing
and i think that's
i feel like i've had there have been
walls in previous stuff because we tried
like crown of sorrow for a while i
remember that being an absolute struggle
uh aatrax was an absolute bear but it's
just i don't think anything in here ever
got to the point even the finale when we
got there it's like that we the
progression was there we kept getting
and then there were like bugs issues and
things we'll have some fun stories but
yeah i like the fact that as you said
the
things kept getting a little bit better
things kept getting figured out progress
was made so i actually really liked that
about this thing yeah it was like for me
it was
i was one of the runners as well so
titan kind of learned to move quick and
just realize the wizards are evil so
dodge those quickly and i knew we were
going to have the different levels
because we looked before it started
we're like okay what's going on in here
somebody made a jumping puzzle second
level and somebody was like up on the
third i was like oh so we got two floors
and so somebody's like nope there's
another one oh crap so you go up there
and you see there's like three doors to
it now
um
yeah we did the same thing we got our
two runners they stuck on rolls two ad
clear and the two stunners and that just
kind of helps everybody know what
they're doing when you get in there but
it was just those little variations of
first he's right on top of you
uh and then a little bit farther a
little bit farther on the top floor that
third room for the runners though man
it's nothing but just a bottomless pit
and a couple platforms in there it is
it's not great it's a pretty big room
decent amount of verticality and a whole
bunch of places to fall to your doom
damn and it's like i've done it on all
three characters and
yeah titan's a little squishy for sure
um just because
but yeah the hunter was nice for the
invis so that i i envy that one on the
first run that would have that would
have been nice in there but yeah it's
like just the verticality of this whole
thing by the time you get done with it
or if you accidentally fell all the way
down a couple levels and you're like
i'll be up in like six hours i'm down
here now that'll kill an entire run
if you get pooped on that encounter or
shout out to them for being little
they've they've been a little messy
there are no osha railings you know the
the building
no railings
no safety concerns but the thing is i
think it's the second flight of steps
that drops down oh if you just run
through it they need to mine the gap
sign yeah my i would tell people your
mind the gap because you will i see
people just race up and then fall to the
cap and that make the platform yeah
that's like the stairs that didn't quite
connect and you know they did that
intentionally and going
um
yep definitely but it was also like when
you're doing the dunks there's a little
space between the platform where you're
doing that that as well and i just kind
of be up there and like try and dodge
and just fall a couple floors down it's
like sorry and there's nothing you can
do but it's like i was happy what did
you
we ended up going with as many catalysts
and like catalyst death bringers as we
could and that actually worked rather
well really yeah tv's been um i got
lucky to play with some cool like some
cool people but death bringer uh yeah
he's like a big death ringer person so
he started with that dps and was killing
us
like we were doing some linears we were
doing some regular rockets um that thing
is just solid
and the cool thing is if you if you can
really learn the timing
you could if you like say well you do
one two your third you can shoot it
higher let it fall get to the plate and
then by the time it hits them you're
still doing the dps that's fine so it's
it's a cool way to do damage that i
would not have thought about without him
uh and that really like raised our
damage a lot so what'd you guys use for
dps
i'm curious about trav views yeah we all
used rockets uh gallerhorn and then we
had a autoloading holster on rockets and
fusion rifles nice we could alternate
between the two and that sort of thing
so we did pretty pretty well dp at dps
at the end and then obviously one person
had gallard horn uh to give us all wolf
pack rounds and
uh i think i was using um
what's the delayed reaction one last
thing
impression lasting impression i had
enhanced lasting impression on one of my
rocket launchers the one that i made and
uh
i was shooting that and sort of doing
exactly what you were doing with
deathbringer like basically delaying the
explosion
damage phases so i'd shoot it on the way
and then stand in the pool and then wait
for the explosion to happen get off two
more rockets and then switch to fusion
and then just keep going from there so i
was doing i think i was doing like five
point
two five point three mil uh wow all
three waves so it's pretty good pretty
good damage yeah
yeah that was a lot of fun i really like
that encounter yeah nina i can't wait to
do it tonight with cog
do you have any unique strats nina let
these guys know the best way to but way
to go best way
um we had multiple hunters so we had the
tether debuff to start
every dps phase um
and you know it was able to pretty much
continue for two plates so
you know and then throw the nade on him
for the last one so keep the debuff on
him um we went sleepers actually okay
okay he's got a pretty big head doesn't
he like spot
yeah we went sleepers and
um
you know we we uh i think we had a well
too because you know squishiness right
so mm-hmm uh and then
like cartesian coordinates like a fast
sheet
fusion you know i think uh what they
sold a vorpal one not too long ago so
everybody has that vorpal rule
and
that was kind of like the the balance
you know for that plate where he's
really close to you you know we were
switching to that and then going back to
sleeper for the place that he was a
little further away
um
yeah i think we we did one well and then
everybody else was just dps supers too
so yeah you know we didn't we were
trying to like really stretch the
survivability without having something
to protect you every plate yeah right
yeah we had probably a couple too many
bubbles and stuff yeah a little more
leaning more into the dps and hold your
own without it was definitely a thing
the farther we got into this encounter
so
nice
uh any any jumping he's not that good in
there no divinity's not needed yeah he
he it's very
he almost instrumental we tried that
yeah yeah
it's very he's a bit bulky
yeah he's he like turns at an odd angle
too so you wouldn't always see it like
it was a little
we we tested it a couple times and then
you know
back to nope everybody's doing dps
um so after that jumping puzzle mostly
kind of working through
we found the secret chest on that
section how was the orchestration of the
jumping and then also the button
switching so you could jump and then the
rotating barrel like ninja warrior
platforms
world our resident warlock is shaking
his head right now how you doing bud
it wasn't that bad as much as i
complained but the one i don't like the
one that was evil was the rotating ones
i i that one
i was like come on this is this is just
wrong
and i was like all right
it was the fact that the surface wasn't
flat that bothered me
oh well i mean yeah like there were six
sides it was like hexagon or whatever
but you also can't clamber though so you
just gotta hit it and go i'm not clever
that so i was like okay this is gonna be
it's just for me but i mean overall
considering it was it wasn't too bad the
switch day was interesting that you know
one person kind of behind and then you
know hit the button all right hit the
doorbell y'all go through whatever
whatever and kind of disappear but um
yeah for the warlock delegation there
was there's some struggles there for a
little bit
i had to switch to the right jump when i
ran my warlock because yeah a couple of
the corners i wasn't using the right
jump and then finally when i switched
it's like okay
now i'm all right but it took me all i
was like these corner turns i'm like i'm
scrum and then finally i was like oh
it's my jump i forgot what i was on so
yeah that makes a difference but yeah
the warlock was the hardest of the three
in there i will give you that
but i will also say the warlock is never
going to die on that initial fall if
you're going for a flawless yeah so
yeah
that's the advantage
uh but yeah the secret chest was a nice
bonus get through and another thing
organically yeah we did that was cool
yeah it's nice nice
and yeah we didn't find the secret chest
on the on their first on day one you
know just running through uh
we did stop that minor you know the
scenery as we kept going you know and
obviously kept looking at the worm and
checking on him to see if anything
like i honestly don't i still don't know
the right way to get through that
jumping puzzle not using the secret
chest path because that's just the one i
found on my first try and so oh now it's
the only path i know so somebody was
like oh skip the chest i'd be like i
don't i don't know how
that is nice
yeah that i liked it though i i felt
that they stepped it up you know
um
i like how close you were to the worm
too that was dope yeah
that was the point where i was like
[ __ ] i think this guy is right about us
fighting on that
later
i was like i was like man we're pretty
close to this uh this this rectangle
again i think i'm in trouble here yeah
yeah like
you know jumping puzzles i've been in
destiny forever right and uh
they're always a source of pretty good
laughs and good memories and
i didn't you know i thought like
they're fun but i never thought they
were really super challenging because
everybody usually you know you have a
main class that you put your most hours
into and you're pretty comfortable with
that you know so i never felt like
you know for anybody that
puts the hours into this game they're
not that hard and i felt this one was
like all right they stepped up their
game a little bit like
like flawless in this raid is gonna be a
pain
yeah
yeah
like this that's gonna be the endurance
test right there yeah people like the
jumping puzzle on the flawless room
those are be like hey you good at
jumping no you're not in this run
gonna have to filter out by good
platform okay let me see your um have
you beat mario
fill in a blank what mario game have you
beaten
no or blind forest would be a good one
yeah oh yeah
both of those are excellent um i will
say we have a warlock main on our team
that you know day two running through
after contest mode she uh she did it on
blink
all of it
except like that one blind
yeah the blind corner yeah
yeah
like i she did all of the all of it up
until like that one quarter like respect
we had to like hurry up a little bit
because one of our friends that we were
running through we had to go so
but she would have gotten it she would
have gotten if we would have gave her a
little more time yeah blake blake
warlocks get all the respect that's a
different level it's a different mindset
right there i love my blink warlocks of
respect okay okay i don't even got the
heart to play that one
you're looking for a challenge later
that's mold with respect
all right nina third encounter
was
was this any kind of a wall for you guys
how was this experience i want to know
from you
how many how long was this one for you
guys
um i want to say this one was probably
um i i don't think we ran into really
any bugs which was nice yeah um
so
you know we kind of our first couple of
attempts were like you know survey in
the area so we just ran through like
chaos theory like look at what's here
see you know make call outs see what's
happening you know
get to the the next kind of checkpoint
the next room you know when we saw that
to make sure that there was no kind of
like
maybe dps or some kind of
you know harder enemy that had to be
taken down or anything like that or any
surprises yeah and then you know after
running that first room a few times and
we saw oh okay we just gotta like
survive we could we all right we could
do this you know
um
[Music]
we probably like oh my god we made it
through
a couple times towards the end and then
forgot the symbols
oh yeah i feel like we had that too
there were a couple times because it's
so hectic and you're like what was
and it just and everybody's just shot at
a point depending on the hours yep
been there yeah
so
we we we had a good rhythm you know and
like you know we were lucky i want to
say hunters were pretty good on this
part because the taken relic to have to
run ahead and cleanse those blights you
know i was just throwing invis needs and
other you know teammates were doing the
same and allowing them to like kind of
get through first
and you know start the progression
really quick
um
and then we uh you know we decided right
away we're gonna split up in two teams
of three and keep it going and
uh i want to say i ran the k-bar shield
the relic
majority of it um nice
yeah and uh
it was easy to get to the other side i
could avoid snipers you know like yeah
you can go invis that's just i'm like i
wish
i'm just sitting and thinking about any
of this invisible and i'm like nope
didn't really have a whole lot of that
finishing yeah so do those finishers
like a handful of failed attempts we
finally didn't trust our memories and
started to write down the symbols so
[Laughter]
yeah
there's not a lot of time
there's no it was only just a few hours
for you guys
yeah i want to say because i'm going to
say
majority of our time was fun at the boss
we made it to the boss in like 10 hours
overall so that's not bad that's pretty
good yeah yeah i'd say for us this was
this is where we called it the first
night was this encounter when we finally
put it together
because we kept getting the same thing
we were getting a little figure out the
first room you're like alright get the
mechanics second room okay we added one
got through the second room finally a
little bit of chaos figured out the
order everybody where i was going found
the third room we're like all right
we've got three and what we ended up
doing that allowed it to work we did two
two for the third and fourth room we did
two two and two two and left two and
right
and then
uh nomad was on the shield and i was on
the taken and we just were together the
entire we just literally ran we'd like
run up shield clear go to the other side
shield clear cleanse run up because you
then you have to clear that one and go
to the other side we were just like
glued together the whole time we were
just like the the shielding clearing
couple running through there so and then
the nice thing is once we figured out
with the darkness the little peanut
thing you could turn around and hit the
night for the time when we got through
the third door we're like we have enough
time so we dumped the relics and waited
and then we'd pick back up the same one
so we had the same jobs
which works really well because you know
if you can get that extra time yeah then
it's two people doing the exact same
thing exact same and only the darkness
has got to switch and those are the two
that have to do the most movement so we
basically made two left two right and
then us two were that job the entire
time and we've got it down to a pretty
good run so it's like so you know if you
start here you look up here then i know
which one's gonna end we just and that's
what made it work but this was our
yeah this was our good six eight hour
like this was
just to
get every little piece you get to the f
we were at the final one and then we
just couldn't quite get the well over
and it was hard to be the taken guy
because depending on how it was set up
until we really started bringing the
shield the cleanse kind of shield bubble
with us
i was just i you have to jump into chaos
to hit the taken eye that's just you
because it's a whole bunch of enemies
and without invis i'm just like please
let me survive and that's all that's all
i had to do for a little while finally
we got the shield going with but for a
while i'm just like there's like 12 guys
up there and i have to get into the
middle of them to cleanse this eye
everybody pray like it was that kind of
moment
a lot and then finally we got the
cleanse together
and then the same thing we finally
learned the positions and it was like
okay the third room we know where the
knights are at so you can extend the
timer that helped a ton uh once you kind
of figured out where those were but it
was just that was the one and the reason
we i think we were able to stick with it
every little every run was just a little
bit or i stubbed my toe here or and
again believe me i even fell with my
titan at some point i was just like i
can jump damn it so you feel really bad
when you drop a relic on like the fourth
room you look
to the beginning and it's
it is it
when it runs smooth it's like six seven
minutes pretty fast but learning that
thing and then now i will say that's
probably gonna be the hardest one to
teach you could probably take two people
and be like one of you each are gonna be
ad clear and that's all you're gonna do
but if you have to teach more than two
people
because if you have like four regulars
you can do that entire section with
people who know what they're doing but
anything past that it's
it's gonna be a lot of work to probably
teach know what to look for and
understand the pieces
yeah yeah yeah
cog what about you're you're shaking
your head pretty heavily
literally you literally explained all
the pain points of what you know it was
not that it was a bad encounter it was
just that it's one of those things it's
it's everyone must do a job like there's
no getting out of it so i didn't even
know about that little trick that you
guys were doing and then come combine
that with that timer right so it's like
the constant movement you know for me
the mistake i think we made in charge of
dj he's in there it's just that we just
had
try to run it's like i always have a
rule like if you try to run an
experienced team with someone who's
never done it minimize the amount of
people who've never done it to like one
or two and the problem we did was last
night was like we had like three people
who don't know so it's just like it's
too much because everyone has to have
you know
you know that that knowledge of it but i
will say that i mean it's a frenetic
pace thing that is cool with it would
execute it and you watch it it's really
cool to see
like you know because what i just from a
lore standpoint i think it's kind of
dope like almost every relic in destiny
history he has and you gotta use like it
is cool
but this is going to break a lot of new
raiders
this is the section i think yeah people
are going to be like yeah they're going
to be like i don't know because you they
know karen you're going unless you
unless they do it the e-trick and people
get that to a science or whatever you
know it's going to be hard to um to
carry people in there you know but
people will come up with stuff
eventually but
like i said i don't hate it it's just i
knew that was the pain i was like yeah
well we have some of the rain stats
actually so what i wanted to just kind
of give us the numbers well there's
other stuff in the swamp i haven't read
but i saw these so players that you know
players that entered the raid
and again that could be anybody of six
random people or even just a solo 546
thousand people entered the raid
that's got to be one of the biggest ones
ever
players that have players that cleared
acquisition first phase 270k still
pretty large
caretaker
131 that just got to be less than half
so that was one of the dps checks
players that cleared exhibition 80k
wow and then full clears which will get
to the last one 32k
players total
and again there were sherpas and stuff
in that time but yeah in the 48 hours
yeah you go six people so again there's
about five to six thousand in that total
48 hours but yeah the caretaker definite
wall exhibition because i i mean that
was the thing about exhibition is with
contest on
you just you couldn't miss it had to be
that executed perfection and with i was
like little by little by little by
little by little i was like come on
it was it was just pure hell um just
hectic though it was just constant crazy
oh yeah
then
a little bit more jumping a little bit
more traversal yeah travis how do you
get traffic
i'm doing the uh the math right now
based on these number of total enemy
defeats versus guardian deaths to see
what the community's kd was
[Laughter]
not good just one sec no no it's pretty
good actually uh i'm i'm almost done
with it uh yeah so guardian deaths there
were over a billion
uh enemy deaths and guardian deaths were
a mere a paltry 70 million
uh so the kd on that uh this is going to
take too long for me to type it on my
phone but uh
it uh it was pretty good yeah um
i'll be honest i i think the third
encounter is the weakest um and i
actually don't even think it's
particularly close um the the
the reason is because they kind of throw
a lot of mechanics at you all at once
and
none of them are
it's not really hard to figure out it's
more just that like there's so much
going on and things that you're juggling
and it feels like they just kind of were
like and we'll throw in the relic from
the the you know the old vaulted glass
raid to keep the pressure on and and
then this and that and it's just it's it
the only real thing that feels like it's
part of that raid and was meant to it
are the call outs where people are
having to find the commonalities and
shoot the door yeah that feels like it's
from the raid the other stuff feels like
it's just random and then the uh running
and gunning i just feel like
it
i never felt like i was fighting
anything yeah really because everything
just even even on the hard mode
everything dies like fairly quickly uh
and and you're kind of you're kind of
just like moving on and so it the fact
that there's no boss or common thing
you're fighting it i feel like um the
the uh the run in last wish did this a
lot better oh yeah oh yeah
yeah it's sort of the same type of
encounter but it it feels uh more
thematic and well-designed than i
thought this one did
but that said it is fun um
and uh getting through it was was cool
and getting to see
sorry getting to see the different scene
changes was also really cool uh i think
that's something that they did really
well in this raid is the fact that
you're you're almost always in almost
every encounter except for the first one
and the first one you're you kind of get
to go into different rooms even which is
cool you're always on the move and going
from place to place and not just in one
room forever which i feel like being
stuck in one room forever
uh is really depressing like the the
damn vault and last wish and so uh this
was cool to like get to run around and
have different scene changes and feel
like you were not only progressing
in the encounter but you were actually
physically progressing and getting to
like see that change and it's like it
just it it's kind of representative but
it also it also kind of um
it gave me like a mental
all right we're in the third room that
means this is a good run rather than
having to be like wait what phase is
this how much do you get
which is kind of cool
yeah that's true that's true yeah
i like these mechanics you know
encounters too
and i i personally think that you know
the mechanics you know blended into dps
is the way that all dps you know kind of
encounters should go i know a lot of
people don't agree with that
they think it's too much maybe
but i like the the chaos you know i like
the everybody's calling out you know and
everybody's you know trying to do their
part and your
your head is like you know doing that
360 thing like
yeah you're just like on a swivel for
sure yeah exactly trying to keep up and
you know pull your weight and you know
it it brings a different level of fun so
yep a little uh yeah and then a little
bit more jumping um we took a little
while to just try and figure out to get
to there
and we didn't figure out until was it
yesterday that all of you just need to
stand
by one of the two doors
to get to the final section
um
yeah we ended up doing some weird jump
around get to the stairs that you can
see far away not necessary totally not
necessary everybody's trying to figure
out where to go
all you got to do is get six people in
front of the door door opens easy
staircase i felt like an idiot when i
figured that out on day two or three so
that was special
um
yeah final encounter so we are gonna go
deep on the final encounter are you okay
with us talking about this [ __ ]
yeah absolutely
um okay guys our kd for the community
and the raid was uh
one 1.4 it's not bad
1.4 kb
not bad
did they say what percentage passed it
like what percentage of people like was
the success success rate there or
further i was like 546 and 546 000
entered 32 000 did the full clear
but it but it also doesn't count uniques
on the other ones and then it does on
the clear raid so i'm wondering if
that distinction is there for a reason
you know i mean yeah because there's
probably a couple sherpas and things
like that that got like i know some
people did like contest sherpas i know a
few were that way but there's probably
not a ton of those i would say
so the fact that it went from 80 to 32
it's probably not like you're looking at
a drastic difference there might be like
35 max i mean there's not a ton of
contest shirping i would imagine that
happened there if you got it you were
probably like i'm out i'm sleeping i
don't care
so i cannot imagine there's a ton of
that going on but yeah total hours spent
involved the disciple 4.2 million hours
between all of the guardians so i don't
know what the divides out per person but
yeah there was definitely some had 39
apparently um i feel like i did half of
those hours
or whatever you could yeah
these past two weeks you have that's for
sure
uh final encounter
so this was the one
i had heard a rumor
that we were getting something different
and all i can say is we damn sure got
something different
um was it a rumor or was it a prediction
on this show
i had heard rumor league other stuff
like i got i got tuned in
i got and i know yeah you did predicted
you were spot on 100 and again i hoped
you would be right honestly because
going into the pyramid ship ancient evil
and you're going
all right come on something cool
and i gotta be honest
this is probably my favorite fight in
all of destiny
wow
that's big from you
wow it's definitely the best final boss
i think easily break it down i gotta
hear this this is this is uh
oh nina because she said this is the one
that they spent the most time on i'll
i'll get my take on it don't you worry
i'm gonna be patient
but nina like this is where you spent
the most time
break it down how to go
uh what were the struggles like do you
have any fun weird i got a fun weird
story so yeah how let me give you your
story about this whole
rolk encounter and this is the dude's
name wrong
yeah uh so
we spent like over a day here um
it was it was pretty uh intense um
i will say though going back to like the
opening the doors we didn't figure that
out either okay no i'm not alone thank
you
we jumped around in the windows and then
jumped and then floated around the
stairs and
yeah
because you're still kind of far from
like you can see the platform but you're
still kind of far and we were like okay
we gotta find the you know more jumping
puzzle or something or i don't know
maybe another level up
or something and
we also had a couple teammates find that
like the roundabout way to the stairs
and went over and started the encounter
yeah i got pulled for sure
yeah so
um
[Music]
but the final boss yeah you know we
we took the same approach we'd we'd been
doing you know we just went in started
right away you know trial and error
you know we figured it out i thought the
mechanic was pretty simple to you know
the glyph keepers to deposit the
resonance you know
and you know the passing of the
of the the leaching force
the force buffs um
we got it we got a
a smooth rhythm down with that pretty
quick um
[Music]
we did
encounter some bugs here too
unfortunately uh couple and did you ever
have him just like not progress after
you dunked what you needed to
exactly that yeah so many times exactly
that he would just
freeze and we found the only way to
progress after that was
you had to get rid of the leaching force
which meant somebody that was carrying
it had to die
and lives were so critical at that point
it was just such a like you know a
gut-wrenching feeling for those bugs at
that time you know because now you know
you're at the end like you know
and you know and you're getting your
rhythm and you're feeling that
progression as you felt throughout the
whole raid and you know we're you're
running into that should we just wipe it
now like do we even bother continuing on
plenty of times that discussion was had
like you know you got a decent pretty
good dps phase in the first time but now
he's bugged out and you're like all
right
we're already down one rose token we're
gonna be down a second do we bother you
know and
it was uh a lot of discussions and you
know
a lot of times we were you know we were
we were taking kind of the analytical
approach to keep track of numbers and
what was working best for dps you know
and we had a couple friends tell us a
couple
you know uh
strats that they were doing too and they
were getting good dps so i think i had a
couple friends streaming so they were
just popping in and talking
with uh each other at the
um at the final boss too and
that was you know that was that was the
hardest thing for us you know we we
probably took like a
good six hours to get a good rhythm here
yeah and then well
yeah the the bugs that would happen
unfortunately um
it would just you know stop our momentum
a little bit and you know
but we we tried to keep the
the morale up and you know
take breaks and
you know
keep the discussion and the chatter
going and
you know we were different time zones
too so wow there you go yeah so you know
we were
we were very aware when we were starting
to hit that 24-hour mark and stuff and
it was you know
so many times we were so close you know
two good dps phases and then the bug to
happen and
you know we we we still had that drive
in us to keep going because we we felt
like we were getting it so
we we kept going for a while um
and so unfortunately it got close to
monday morning and i had
to sign off to get a few hours of sleep
for work for a meeting at 8 am
so
i bowed out and i think
the group stopped right around then too
and all took like the break and then
came back to it a few hours later
and
they knocked it out so
so did they finish it before contest but
you just weren't able to be there for it
basically
no i jumped back in after my meeting
around 11 30 in the morning so
and
uh
they um they were you know still going
through and getting clears on the
checkpoint at the boss right there so i
was able just to jump in with a couple
other people that still needed the clear
so yeah so
yeah the fact that you guys you had it
you're like we know everything to do we
understand it and you went back in post
contest is that right it was
pre-connected oh no no you got it it was
still contest
yeah it was still contest mode yeah so
that's uh
i don't know if you know looking back
now we should have
waited you know and maybe seeing if the
bugs cleared up
you know but so many times we were just
having great runs great dps you know
because we spent so many hours trying to
figure out what dps works what's the
best strats
you know and then
one of our teammates was like you know
obviously we needed somebody making
heavy constantly and
things like that so
you know
it was
it was uh hard to put down
when you felt like you were making
progression and
at this point you know a couple
team members had rotated out because
they were getting pretty tired so yeah i
can imagine that for about two straight
days
gotta get them fresh bodies how you
doing when did you sleep last why were
they why were they tired exactly i don't
think i understand
i was laughing because i was saying i
was like i woke up like saturday morning
and then i woke up monday morning for
work
that was my entire weekend that's an
ouch yeah that that definitely hurts a
little bit couldn't do it man couldn't
do it we got all the time test mode
clear so hey yeah you got it we were
yeah
uh do you want to go travis before i go
into mine
story of fun yeah you can go
yeah yeah uh i i really like the final
boss um
i predicted before that this would
happen and the reason i predicted it
would happen is because i feel like it
had to um
i one of my biggest pet peeves about
destiny and i know you guys know
practically all my pet peeves about
destiny because i talk about them all
the time but um
one of my biggest pet peeves is the fact
that they reuse the basic models for
characters as bosses and it's just it's
so irritating it's like all right
today we're fighting a big old version
of the thing that you've been killing
this whole raid and also the whole
expansion and it's just like all right
i'm over it and so
my favorite part of the raid wasn't even
really like seeing the final boss
although that was super cool and i
screamed like a crazy person because i
walked up to him while he was doing his
little animation i was like hey guys
this guy's a ninja and then he did that
whole bubble flip
and uh rip rip the ears of all the
people in my party because i screamed
like a crazy person
but uh
that wasn't even my favorite part my
favorite part is when the raid started
and rook started talking to me and i
realized he was gonna be the final boss
and i realized that i was correct and
that they were finally like using the
raid to set up the next expansion and
telling story and i was just like yes
yes yes this is like all the stuff i've
wanted from a raid um and so i was super
stoked about that uh and then getting to
the final boss and getting to see him do
those ninja moves and clearly being a
completely different model with
different uh you know animations that
aren't part of other characters and he
doesn't just have a stomp he's got a
kick in the face so kick you right in
the face which i thought was really cool
um yeah so
uh i i don't think that encounters
particularly hard granted i got over
halfway through the raid and then
uh my friends were like all right that's
day one of this two day
uh marathon down
ready to log on after four hours of
sleep and get get another 20-hour day
and i said hey man i thought this was
gonna be a 24-hour period and i'm not
willing to give the other day of the
weekend up sorry man i it wasn't even it
wasn't even just a
a i actually think we probably could
have beaten it in fact the group i was
with did go and beat it on day one uh uh
after after they they replaced me but
uh it was more just like i needed to use
sunday to write the rest of my review oh
yeah
yeah and also to catch up on the because
my review was due monday morning uh and
i also had to catch up on the um the end
game quests that unlocked once people
started beating the raid so i i
basically just had to make a call like
do i do i want to kill myself with
another 20 hour day just so i can beat
it on the first day or do i
you know get work done and then beat it
on monday and that's exactly what
happened monday i beat it uh you know
got through the final boss and all that
and then and then wrote the rest of my
review and all that stuff and i really
really like the final encounter a ton
the mechanics are pretty easy to me the
dps phase at least on non-contest mode
we're super generous we beat it in two
uh phases just because non-cons
yeah on contest i'm sure it's different
but i felt like damn they let you shoot
this guy for a while like after when
he's up there and probably just because
he's moving he's not a static target
which is cool um or frustrating
depending on on your inclination um and
i really for me
now that we've gone through all the raid
my
my thoughts overall are that at least in
my experience
it is a really good raid but i have a
really hard time knowing where it sits
yeah pantheon of other raids just
because it was so buggy
and
i i i honestly like there was no there
was no encounter in that raid where i
wasn't having issues
it was done like the first one all the
dc's the second one the totem not pop
not responding when you shoot it the the
fourth one the the boss not going into
damage phase like every single encounter
had problems well you might have to rank
it once you play a little bit more and
it smooths out a bit for sure for sure
and uh you know now i've run it multiple
times i even sherpa the first half of it
uh right after it exited contest mode
because i was just playing with an lfg
group and trying to show them how to do
it um so
you know like i i realize that when it
works the the that it's good it's just
that it leaves a really bad taste in
your mouth and it's that's just true of
the entire expansion to be honest like
it probably would have been a nine
without the bugs to be honest but
there's so many i believe there's so
many bugs in the witch queen and and it
it it really makes it hard with the
state of pvp and the state of uh gambit
and all that stuff plus the unpolished
kind of feel of which queen made it
really tough for me to to justify nine
um in the review and uh i i have to say
that about the raid in general as well
as like the the bugs really really
rained on my parade uh when it comes to
that it sounds like i'm i'm hearing the
same thing from you nina uh that like
you want it so badly to love it and to
get through it
especially to to put 39 hours into it
and
uh
almost not make it like there was
there's a world where you wouldn't have
made it because of bugs like that really
just sucks right yeah um and i have no
idea how well my my group would have
done if i didn't encounter six hours of
non-stop decent yeah
i might have been able to beat the raid
i will never know so yeah uh yeah
we tried to go to orbit and reset the
instance and you know take out breaks
like we tried that yeah we tried that
who's the host right now
switch up the desync issues shout out to
dj oros real quick 10 super chat what's
up guys long time fan and listener of
the show
i just wanted to know what's your most
ridiculous but accurate call out your
team's had
sorry if i missed this uh joining late
uh we covered some of those
uh i'm gonna say ours for sure green
floyd stix
i'm living and dying by green floyd's
gonna say iron man iron man two iron man
iron man the whole heart that's iron man
those two yeah even more than green
floyd because i keep hearing community
about iron man that's
yeah that's not yeah get the hole in the
heart of grief but like yeah iron man it
just works so yeah that's ours
what
no i'm gonna say dj saying chicken
fingers that was fine chicken fingers
was pretty funny that's hilarious
yep
okay final boss for us
uh you get up there to the encounter i
don't even get to see him first because
i get pulled ahead
right i didn't even know about the kick
flip until we ran back on like the
second time after contest
he was warning us
yeah he's like by the way this guy does
new things
yeah i mean i think you guys have both
said it like the mechanics themselves of
getting two damage
kind of got understood pretty quick
you're like okay i got this thing and
then
now i will say the first time you see
we got to see a little bit of it with
the caretaker
little floaty grenades
you got to see a little bit of whatever
his
damage type is per se
um
he has giant laser beams of a damage
type we've never seen in this game
and i will take a little tangent here to
say there is a mural somewhere in this
raid
and it shows prism of light on one side
we kind of see those things and then you
get to see what looks kind of like
stasis
you get to see a symbol that kind of
looks like the hive poison and you get
to see a symbol that kind of looks like
his stuff and it's a it's my wonder
somebody had like a wondering or
something like that is if we're going to
be seeing this as theoretically the
other darkness classes
so i mean oh yeah
because it's so unique it's so unique
it could be the one that's not hive
poison like the hive poison feels like
that's got to be a thing
about that forever yes like but this one
could be the final shape type
and i feel like if we're gonna end up
with six if we're gonna end up with an
even number
like this is the first time we see
something that i think has potential to
be that unique
but he's got these big giant laser beams
lights you up you get your buff you do
the dunks
this is destiny's first mini mini souls
boss
now you know why i like it
that's i'm like yo this is
i was i'm shocked right now for what i
do
and i have been build obviously yeah the
dexterity build yeah that's the hunters
for sure nina's like maxed out on
dexterity she's an assassin
so many bosses stand still so many
bosses are a target to shoot and i've
been honestly thinking back to taking
king i'm like where does this rank
because
you got a lot of bosses
but they're all freaking static
and you got oryx which is legit
this
fight is exactly what i want more of in
this game
because
you've got to build up to set up the dps
it's good communication you get the
mechanics you've kind of built up to it
and again like managing that even on
contest we got that like butter smooth
we're like yep okay we understand the
dps i figured out you could double dunk
later we got that method down we ran
back later so it's even faster to get to
dps so it's actually pretty quick um but
even just the singles we had that smooth
we had the three of us rotating going
going had it
it's the dps phase
and it's what you have to do kind of
combination but then it's the fact that
he has a telegraph
and then the dude's gonna charge across
the boss platform and he's either going
to kick you or punch you or swing his
staff and then he's going to mean around
and then he has an aoe attack
and then
and then you have the ability to kind of
stun him
all of those things went into just the
fact that
on top of the fact that he is the most
unique enemy we have ever seen in this
game
um
i don't know if you've seen his model
yet if you've missed it on twitter some
yeah i was like there's no way twitter
has not exploded that one for you um
so unique looking and just like zero
care that were there it was hilarious
because he's mocking you in the middle
of the fight
he's basically saying hey did you see
all those ghosts back there i had some
fun he was just giving you crap the
entire time on the fight walking around
like he doesn't care that you're there
and i just really enjoyed the fact that
like this is
you know it's like what's a souls fight
big wind-up or a telegraph move or
understanding a combo
and you got to do the same thing with
this guy and
we there's a point he's got a platform
like you'll be at a lower level you do
the mechanics you run up the stairs you
fight him you get dps phases you'll
rotate through that
there's like an upper there's like
you know architecture above
there's like two big blocks and there's
big opening now i don't know if anybody
else has seen this it's recorded
somewhere in my hours of footage he just
out of nowhere was walking around and
all of a sudden just
shoots up into the air off the platform
and floats and we can't even see him up
there in the middle of the damage phase
he is up where we cannot see that man
off the planet so he just all of a
sudden superman straight off the
platform and we're just sitting there
like
well i think this is going to be a wipe
because we can't touch him he finally
came down at the end of the damage phase
yeet
yeah he just yeah he just yeted himself
straight up and i was like bye
he finally came back but that killed the
entire run uh at least that one attempt
um
but he's just so unique i enjoyed the
mechanics um contest dps was tight i
mean there's no question when you get to
it was three phases full we got the dp
and what killed us is we never got back
to it because this is where the desync
issues come up
his area of effect
is basically a cross of four lasers
and you would stand and say like in
between them and then all of a sudden
when he goes to fire the laser would be
here
i hated that that happened to us too and
that wiped it is happening yeah people
like i mean
i was playing with some good people it's
like they're like i'm looking right at
it and now i'm dead cause all of a
sudden you're in the laser and you're
like here it is here it is here it is
now it's in my face
if you have the buff you're trying to
get hit by the laser also wouldn't help
me because it would slow me down because
i'm like i just got hit
i didn't get the buff i'm in the middle
of the laser beam and i didn't get the
buff so the dsync issues were probably
the biggest killer for us because the
laser beams if you and then when you get
to the dps phase it's like six instead
of four so it's an even tighter window
so if it moves you're kind of screwed
either way
we had him in final stand down to
three or four percent
that was as close as we got him
we never got him back to a complete
finishing contest
we went in
booted up the raid after contest was
done literally
two phase and it actually says my raid
clear because it was like either the
next day or whatever my raid clear is 11
minutes
we literally logged in killed him and
beat it and that was the first because
we didn't even we too phased him the
first time because we had it so packed
but honestly like the way this whole
raid is done the mechanics to it
the difference of the encounters the
verticality
this is the progression that i want all
destiny raids to go
because we have the lore and the story
being hugely integrated and then post
rate as well we get to learn so much
about this guy if there was like a
mission on the dreaming city where we
got to know this is the history of
ahamkara's we get to learn more about
riven and what her his that type of
stuff would have like may have set that
one over the top the fact that you go
back to preservation now and you get a
1500 second cooldown to go listen to
this guy talk to you for a while about
what he's been through the levi all
these things
the culmination of what this was was
just exactly what we all like we wanted
story we got so much of it it's not even
just funny we wanted a unique boss
travis nailed that one uh in a
completely unique model
uh i wanted like new bosses because i
was that's the thing that makes me sit
here and debate
what is every boston taking king
shoot the static thing
shoot the static thing i mean obviously
we know oryx is different where it's the
bombs which is its own thing but it's
like nobody really loved the bombs per
se because you never shot him so you
never killed him
so it's just like the combination of all
of these people and then the aesthetic
the the skybox
and then the pyramid architecture and
then the preservation of the museum
all of this combined for me
i know there's going to be some recency
bias
it's my number one right now
yep
it's my number one so that's why i
wanted to ask you guys where does this
fall in your rankings at this point i
know cog hadn't beat it he's gotta do
the [ __ ] finish
i'm just analyzing but it's my number
one destiny rate at this point and not
number one expansion as well so this is
this is the bar now for like lightfall i
do not envy
the people making lightfall because this
whole combination of expansion set a
very very good bar for destiny it got an
eight as he literally said like 8.9 this
is the that oh the music too
so fitting the ambiance of this place as
well
wait i do envy the people making light
fall
to be honest
because
because it's the last of two uh
expansions e and the in fact it was
supposed to be the last one before they
announced it right in the saga so they
get to just like do all payoff you know
what i mean like even the witch queen it
had to hold back a little bit and i feel
like we're now we're in the down slide
of the roller coaster where it's just
all gravy right like all the building up
and like alluding to
future bosses is gone and now it's just
like it's here we're gonna get answers
to all of our questions we're going to
start fighting the people that we've
been promised we were going to fight all
this time and like i i'm just i'm so
excited for what's coming and i i think
that
um
yeah it has to be better right like it
had it we have to get like a new mob
type in here or some something to shake
up the sandbox it has to be something
super surprising at the end of the
lightfall raid and i i have no idea what
it's going to be but i'm i'm
i i'm just so hopeful for the franchise
this this makes me hopeful even though
there were a bunch of bugs that i think
ruined a lot of my initial run and all
that stuff like
i don't i don't know where it ranks
overall e because i think i think you
know recency i know a problem i mean and
it may be there but yeah and bugs are a
problem too so it's both right there's
two things kind of at play but i will
say when it comes to story
yeah by far no comparison
when it comes to the environments and
the stuff that they did like no
comparison for me when it comes to the
final boss no comparison like it does so
many things
final boss no no comparison i mean
exactly
big oryx is great
but he's just a big oryx he's the same
wizard-like
uh hive guy that you've been fighting
forever there's nothing like uh the the
disciple in the game and that's really
what gets it for me is that it's just so
cool i i mean i i never thought that
oryx was the best boss fight in the game
i i've always
told you guys this many times i i still
think siege engine is the best encounter
i don't know if you call it a boss but
it's the best encounter that's a counter
it's a funny comment it's a fun
encounter but yeah i i have a hard time
ranking it but i will say like uh it
does certain things better than any
destiny right so far and i i now expect
them to
chase that and go in this direction
another thing that i really like is
people
who are uh last wish sims
which i will never understand
that's disrespectful wow
that's so disrespectful we gotta get her
rankings here in a second but we don't
know
calling them
the thing i will never understand about
that is that lore wise
that entire exp that entire raid is
nonsense basically right it's like oh
this is sacroiliac we got to shut you
down right this is
i understand you guys are in the prison
of the moment but we are not going to be
disrespectful now i will let you know
then explain
the the wish the the alma car the last
wish the dreaming city of being in the
perpetual state after the raid one of
the coolest things of race that didn't
we thought didn't exist anymore like
what
explain explain to me the inner workings
of what is happening in the last wish
rate
going to kill riven the last amenkara
yeah that's been in the lore for destiny
law for forever what is there not to
understand what would we confused by
i mean explain to me the vault what's
happening in that encounter oh you're
talking about each mechanic all right
emblems and the significance of that
like i i get that that's how they
decided to make the wish but it doesn't
have the same like connection directly
to the story
he alluded to it earlier where it feels
like a raid that kind of doesn't belong
in the expansion like they were making
two separate things and they're not
really connected whereas this one feels
like
it it picks up right where the story
leaves off with the witch queen and the
final cut scene you see and it feels
like it's almost the it's almost the the
the 0.5 version of the witch queen it's
it like adds on to it it's like its own
little mini expansion whereas the last
wish is like all right you got revenge
on kade now fight a dragon and yeah
kids
it's so silly the techies
the the the wish the connection to
savithoon with the taken how they were
tricked like th there's lore but cobalt
don't do that you're telling me
you fully understood and thought that it
was significant in the lord i'm not
saying it's back when the last wish came
out you're telling me yeah you're making
it better i'm not saying it's better
than lore wise i'm giving y'all law i
can't comment too much because clearly i
can't fit all i'm gonna say is
that
what last wish did was the first attempt
of connecting
campaign story into the right well
that's the first but technically
whatever but yeah take care with the
first 10k with the first you're right
but last wish did it better
last wish literally changed the
environment the dreaming city literally
became one of the greatest like sky
boxes as a result of a of a campaign
that we've ever seen like we we opened
up something completely different and
then we found out about this dish but
i'm gonna let you all have this but the
question i got for you this is what i
really wanted i really wanted to argue
that part but i wanted to ask y'all this
the rope thing right cause y'all y'all
going there right y'all going there
y'all like yo
and this is really for e because we
fought about
oryx i failed for a while right and and
kings fall
so so my question is like
i know how much you this means to you
and for you to say that yeah
that hit i was like oh wow trav we're
going to let him pass it
but
before you don't get to you try i'm
gonna get because you're being very
disrespectful
you're like gotta get that question
there now yeah i will say like i mean
yeah you can break down every encounter
it's like okay what's the idea of the
exhibition encounter and you're like you
could go into laura on literally any
encounter on any raid but also it's like
for travis to sit there and say you know
and this is stuff i don't always know
but i know some do then they're saying
like what is the vault the vault is
locking riven behind magic now do i know
who morgeth is an encounter is he like
the the gatekeeper to the vault he could
be i don't know sir oh she's like you
know taking witches and stuff like that
which is that you had to go in there
that were possessed yeah so i was like
that's what i was like there's last
wishes to it for sure and like it makes
more sense than like the taking king
that's that's i'll give you that but i'm
i'm more just saying like do you think
what percentage of people who completed
the last wish understood what they were
doing
that's fair what percentage
is less than two percent because i i
think it's less than two percent well
done we gotta let nina talk yeah okay go
ahead nina yeah
i felt like last wish was the building
blocks you weren't supposed to get
everything they were just starting to
build the story yep and they purposely
left a lot of mystery there
that's how i took last wish like i agree
i i still don't think that makes it
better i i i don't yeah i agree it's not
complete yeah you can say it's a 1.0 but
my my really my problem with it is that
like what percentage of people do you
think are gonna understand what's
happening in this raid when they beat it
i think it's gonna be way more than any
other raid that we've gotten even even
the taken king i think people kind of
understood okay we're fighting him again
but they don't understand the whole
mechanics of throne worlds and stuff but
i yeah that that's my problem with last
week she's just way too disconnected or
like you don't even really understand
how it fits in destiny or what you're
doing unless you go and you read a bunch
of grimoires which is always destiny's
problem that you have to read a bunch of
grimoires to understand what's actually
happening and so you can go and tell me
oh yeah you're locking the magic behind
a ball it's like okay well i don't get
that when i'm playing the game i have to
go and read a bunch of scrolls to find
that out and i don't have to do that
with with uh that's right i could
say that it you literally had to be
there from the beginning of destiny to
understand this rate you literally like
there there's no for anyone new to
coming to this right i don't know who
the hell the darkness is or whatever no
no no no no you can you can play the
witch queen and nothing else understand
who the disciple is and who the witness
is and then jump into the raid and
understand that you know how i know
because my girlfriend did that and she
was like oh so now we're starting to
fight the guy at the end of the cutscene
this is cool so this is what the next
year destiny's gonna be like and i was
like yeah exactly
okay
and guess what if she if she went and
played the campaign for forsaken and
then jumped to the right she'd be like
what is any of this like
there's a lot of chris there at the
moment stuff going on but i'm gonna let
this rock
it's very disrespectful the last wish
i'm gonna let this rock
let's just rock
very well
to say it makes more sense in the
narrative and it feels like part of the
expression but the way you trash last
wish was like it's completely
nonsensical like that i can't yeah
okay why are we doing that like i'm with
you there but there was
lead up
to last week like we can't just
completely act like they were just throw
the game i mean you had like
talking to you as different voices
during the encounters you had
i mean you had the client
i'm not saying it's not it's savithoon
tate literally possessing a dragon of
course it's confusing but like
i was like i
you can have your opinion on if it's
confusing or not and believe me i'm
ranking vow of the disciple very very
high but i also hold last wish in pretty
high esteem as well because of what it
did like you
if you go through and you say every
single encounter is going to be this
like what the hell is the purpose of the
zamboni then again same thing
it's just like dude
encounters we can literally do that for
every encounter it's
how are the destiny
this is the fun fight like that's what
i'm looking for
to me as and you said it well is the
fact that the package for valve the
disciple with which which queen is what
did it the best and that's exactly i'm
not arguing that for sure i'm not again
but i also think the taken king did it
better than the last wish
they're very connected you see i mean
the end scene is is him taking himself
the camp the raid is you going to the
throne world fighting through his
henchmen and eventually killing him like
that to me
makes sense and the the reason last wish
lost me is i think just to be clear i
think the raid is super cool but it is
super confusing and feels very
disconnected from forsaken has nothing
to do with cade or the crow or any of
that stuff it basically is setting up
this other thing with nothing to do with
it that's my problem that's all
all i will say is this is again as a
raid
right
that is a very very high quality rate
that that raid is i can't let and i'm
not that's not even money more like that
raid is amazing and the fact that you
killed the yamakara and come out with
the heart and just the theatrics with it
and the the amount of detail that they
did
with the heart holder and the people
inside and i get it i know you're going
with the law but the the basic
foundation of law was there with teching
which is the the dreaming city being
possessed the awoken world you know the
last amankara there is significance to
that that people that follow the law i'm
not saying that it's better law wise
than vile disciple i'm definitely not
saying that all i'm just saying is put
some respect in it it's still up there
that's all it says we ain't going to
just throw it as this trash read all of
a sudden
but anyway continue i want the rankings
now and i want to know where you at with
it traffic
where is this all now in the grand
scheme of things now you beat it
ranking
number one that's what we're doing like
what are we doing with vowel disciples i
i mean i think it's number one in
certain areas and lord in terms of its
connection to the campaign stuff like
that i don't know if i'm if i'm ready to
slap a a letter grade on it overall
though just because of the bugs and the
other stuff i experienced and also
because it's so recent but i'll say it's
it's definitely better than last wish
okay i'll just throw that out there
i think probably
it's pretty close to the taken king in
my mind i really really have a
love of the taken king encounters um it
has the best final boss i'll say that
okay you definitely said the best best
that was definitely the best file boss
definitely lost um
and uh
prior to my disciple what was your
number one rate it was it was vault of
glass but also vault of glass i i grade
it on a curve which i don't know if i
should because at the time when i played
vaulted glass i played nothing like it
before i agree now if you go back and
play it you're kind of like all right
well this is not that great compared to
what we have now but at the time right
when i played vaulted glass the first
time it was like a life-changing
experience so it's just hard to it's
kind of hard i'll all i'm going to pass
to be honest and i'm going to let nina
talk because i don't know i want to know
her like i want to know where nina's at
on this yeah yeah i want to know where
nina stands because she clearly is a
last wish stan
uh so
or or more than you just pile it on not
at all not at all no you're not okay no
not at all i will just say that last
wish built
was came at a time where destiny's story
was crumbling and like you know
convoluted itself they had started a lot
of things and dropped them and last wish
was the first step in starting to pick
everything up and tie it together
so like i can't like overly judge it for
not being
you know perfect and complete and
answering everything and connecting
everything
because it was just the kind of the
writing of the path of the destiny to
story and narrative
okay
that's why like i i i've probably only
done that read five times honestly i
can't wait to beat this rape
so i gotta go like top three raids
apparently or were you gonna make this
one and also top three
yeah good question i'm you know i'm i'm
a vault of glass fan girl too
and
one of the things that stands out with
me is number of encounters every raid we
keep getting i feel like i can blow
through in under a half hour now like
number of encounters i don't need like
things to be overly dragging on like and
just dragging on for time's sake
but number of encounters should be there
and
i feel like you know dsc
you know the four encounters you know
with one being a mechanics only now we
got val the disciple
two are mechanics only four encounters
and that brings it down a notch for me
but i can't count
i will say the final boss is the best
final boss though true that for sure
i've wanted to get away from stage
bosses that just stand there and walk
back and forth like pacing in a circle
it's a good way to describe it yeah
yeah you know i wanted an arena style
boss you know i haven't really played
you know elden ring or any of those
types of games but you see them where
you're trapped in like an arena and the
boss is moving and coming at you and you
know you got to be constantly reacting
you know it's not like crota let's go
you know chill back here and sit in this
room and we're fine for a while you know
like
i wanted something that you know
more mechanic more gonna you know be
involved
um and you know that everybody had to be
involved in the raid not like you know i
could carry you through you could just
kind of sit back over here you're fine
like
um
i would say this raid would benefit a
lot from another dps type
encounter
like another boss
yeah like another mini boss you know and
yeah
i thought you know like taking king did
that really well with like the two
sisters you know that was like a mini
boss right there you know
um
they changed up obviously the boss fight
style and you weren't really doing dps
on oryx but
i liked the you know that pre-encounter
a lot and i think reeds now could
benefit from that like yeah
you know i even we we ran a dsc just the
other day you know and again today and i
was saying the same thing like you know
this is so short like this is just a run
through like this is you know people
call
oryx or crota a strike well how is that
different than scourge how is that
different than dsc right now
so yeah um
i can agree with travis on the lore and
everything and the story connecting and
it's it's they've painted a much better
picture here they've really stepped up
their game you know and it ties into the
campaign greatly
and
you know this
it's hard for me not to say taken king
is not my favorite expansion
that's what i thought he was going to do
i said i'm surprised that's right
that's what it means
it's a testament to what you guys are
saying though
for it i'm sorry to interrupt um correct
to to to to have this effect on both of
you right all of you like that's the
power of our disciple right now and i'm
like okay this this is something but i
never thought the day it would kind of
shake e office grade i never thought
trav would kind of put it there either
so this is this is a bomb blowing moment
for me like i'm like wow okay i got to
do this this is impressive continue good
dj uh one sec i gotta let chat know this
very important fact
so um
yeah the the i think it's not really
fair to to do the comparison of like
which one was better taken king or
witch queen and my reason for that is
like vanilla d1 was
so
in a bad place
you know that was such a 1.0 it felt
like a beta right and and the taken king
was such a massive leap forward that i
think everyone who played destiny at
that time feels super fondly about the
taken king and i think there's no doubt
in my mind that
that and i think there's probably no
doubt in anyone's mind that uh the witch
queen is nowhere near as big of a leap
forward as the taking king was because
beyond light was already pretty good
right and and this is a this is a
smaller leap in the right direction and
i think that that is um
that that's kind of hard to judge it
based on that because we're living in a
different era of games two consoles
cycles later uh in in a world where the
games as a service is now a
well-developed place and not just a
canary in a coal mine where bungie was
the only one doing it uh you know
there's like it's just so hard to
compare the two uh but
um you know i would say destiny is
better now than it ever has been even if
it was a less ambitious leap forward
than the taking king was over vanilla d1
so it's really hard to compare those two
i would say
uh witch queen is a better game because
it has more stuff that the taking king
frankly didn't have uh and and that just
makes it a better game overall but uh
but but the taking king was a much
bigger like shift like in terms of
improving destiny as a as a concept like
you you would be
i think you have a really tough argument
to say that any any expansion has
affected destiny so deeply like i don't
think destiny would be around without
the taking king but it probably would be
around without witch queen you know and
that's that's why it's kind of hard to
to compare him well we got the legend in
here someone else
yeah yeah we get the legend we're going
to shout this guy because
he's very passionate shout out to
scarole the legendary scout man um
he yeah yeah he said him he said his
death
that's huge from him yeah that is huge
from him because he's number one wish
yeah yes he's number one which here's
the thing scarole
where's cakes fall like like
this what what look i like rather i go
for i do like yeah
but damn
this is a that's a tough crowd
no and i think it's the combination of a
lot of things is
bungie has a very difficult task like
that's why i was like i don't envy who's
making
say lightfall and lightfalls raid is
because
what this expansion did
versus what came before taking king was
a great experience because he had crota
build into taken king taken king
regicide take you into lightfall
actually take out our first high of god
at scale the big wow moment of like my
god i'm gonna get squished like that was
a very cool moment then we had wrath of
the machine we got to see siva go crazy
with like uh axis and
all of those other things
scarole we're gonna put you a time out
this may i say
oryx is easily the top five worst
ignorant no but
you want to know why i kind of i kind of
agree no i was like i'll tell you why
happiness mechanics twice yeah because
you're killing ogres and you're
basically killing him with taking bombs
the scale no one's ever gonna say hey
oryx isn't a cool looking guy i don't
think i don't even think scara would say
someone has their worm this is not the
same
tell me honestly do you like the
mechanics of the the uh taken king fight
the mechanics the stuff you're doing
which is basically not what's trying to
do somebody jumps around on invisible
platforms and you wait for them to
finish doing that it's unfulfilling
as an encounter it's kind of rough it's
kind of rough it's not very satisfying
yeah though everything everything about
it is cool but except for the actual
things you're doing in it but but the
cheetah said the cheetah would fight
with me to the death about who who are
these guys but no that's no that lat
king's fall is still one of my favorite
raids in destiny that i've done for
different reasons because
like the aesthetic the number of boss
fights you that you've got because you
guys have said encounters no i've said
i'm getting there
like i mean you had golgoroth and there
were the different ways that you were
able to do that fight there he is there
he is you i'm not saying that's not
there i'm just saying
yeah this is still there i'm just saying
i completely 100 understand if scara was
like
hey this guy looks amazing but i hate
setting up bombs and standing in them
like i get that part of it the epicness
of taking out oryx in his grandeur form
in his throne world that's pretty cool
you're literally on a ship sitting
outside of saturn there is epicness to
that thing and that is why it's still
always been very high for me i never
said that it wasn't
but for me the combination of again this
also started in last wish
sabbath building the death batteries
trying to satisfy a worm now we have her
literally pleading with the traveler
getting the light going through all of
that seeing the witness going into valve
the disciple seeing some brand new enemy
inside of a pyramid ship that we've been
teased for a couple of years seeing the
architecture the giant ass worm like the
thing in the back that we get to the
fact that now i know you can see start
to finish when you almost walk in the
door
it is the culmination of what bungie has
done for raids and for me it does right
now sit at the pinnacle of destiny raids
and
between again you guys are like
aesthetic amazing absolutely cool
encounters and i
if it was just another boss boss boss
boss boss the way taking king was
i don't know
i wouldn't i'm i'm with nina i wouldn't
mind one more
i'll be there that's my nitpick
but my nitpick is that
the totems is not really an encounter
it's just you know symbols i mean
it's going to be vault vault is going to
be
you know and there's another version of
yeah we just said on on the frenetic we
just put every relic from every raid and
everybody just run through that's really
not an encounter to me like i'm like hey
i'm gonna be honest caretaker fire
leading up aesthetics lore fire boss i'm
taking y'all word for i don't even i
completely agree for y'all to say this
about rock i'm bending the knee i know
it's that
but i can name two encounters right now
that those two us are are you out of
wait are we kind of that the the are we
coming we're not counting the first
leading up one attack opening segment
no i didn't okay
that's opening vault so i mean okay
but i could those two the two accounts
that i mentioned to me i could take the
i could do demerits okay
the same way you got to demerit vault
the same way because you have templar
and you have atheon and that's it
i'm talking kingsford i'm not even
talking about your favor
i know there's your favorite but you are
knocking your own down as you say it so
i'm like yeah but vault is playing by a
separate set of rules though e it's like
that's like saying like oh the graphics
on you know super mario 64 suck you know
what you're saying let me get started
saying like it it came out as like a it
was it built the entire foundation on
which it's built on and for a game that
came out in 2014 a raid that came in
2014 yeah it is it is incredibly
impressive like
now you play it and you're like
i gotta get
it is reused assets okay that whole
joint is wreath that's a remix that's an
old mixtape you've never done an
encounter like that you've never done an
encounter like the joint that he talked
about that he's pom-pom and woo-hoo-win
is literally vote the glass is literally
levi it's every raid we already did say
hey here's the relics you've been doing
we're gonna put them in one encounter go
run through a room with a timer there's
nothing fire about that yeah it's just
it's reusable
you don't know what that encounter is
like in contest running perfectly
polished and actually having a team that
synergizes when you are running that
encounter and it is run right
that encounter feels better than most
things you're going to do standing still
it's doing this thing standing still
doing this thing because you are moving
you have to agree it's not that original
though like
i'm kind of in between you two like i
have i think that that's the worst
encounter in the in the raid but i don't
think it's especially bad like kaga's
saying i just think it's sort of like
it's like yeah you know it's like all
i'm saying like you listen we're talking
these raids let's be honest the
definition of destiny 2 is where you
used to be he's got a place all these
raids are greatness right now we're just
nitpicking these are all great
encounters we're just nitpicking all i'm
saying is there's nothing new
and nothing like caretaker
can't you take a silent show by the way
but i probably got that
caretaker i'm with y'all but that other
encounter and then the totem it's cool
don't get me wrong but it's not like
wowing that's i'm just saying like we
could take a little demerits from it
that's why i'm not saying they're
terrible i'm not saying they're trash
i'm not saying they're not fun i'm not
saying that i'm just saying that
i i think
maybe a good way to put it is they're
not what you think of when you think of
this raid
when you think of the the devout
disciple you're never going to be like
oh i loved the part where there were
totems you know what i mean like you're
going to be like you're going to think
of the caretaker and that interesting
fight and you're going to think of the
final boss especially like and then all
the environments and the jumping puzzle
like those are things i think of but it
does it does feel a little filler-ish
thank you that's a lot
speak with your heart a little bit
that's what's all i'm saying just a
little bit
after a little bit okay i was like no
for me it's like when you go through
something of the levels of caretaker
you're escalating the scale and that
thing and then you go through the
jumping puzzle you're like all right now
instead of just like hey here's some dps
phases and stuff like that this is pure
teamwork coordination i said that you
are
you just told me like you pull too many
new people in there it is going to be
rough so
having that thing run smooth is watching
a little bit of poetry to go through
that thing smoothly actually and it's
not like it's not new you've still got
the darkness who can see one of the
glyphs from the one side
you've got the other one in the middle
wheat what is the darkness or like
that's a brand new one dude
that's not there
the taken eye also for breaking the
actual eyes
you have the vault relic i will give you
that one for the cleanse i'm literally
saying i will give you that one
literally stole vaulted glasses of
course i feel awake
also it kind of feels like i don't know
why that is in that encounter like do
you have a good reason why that's there
i mean this dude is a collector of all
things
that you're randomly gaining stacks of
darkness unless you get it burned off
and it like i feel like they didn't
really set that up or earn it in that
encounter is that fair to say that it
just kind of pops out of nowhere and
then you don't see it again for the rest
of the raid
i agree
i was like adventist thoughts yeah i was
like it's like we're three people who
talk way too much you can see how this
goes every so often i apologize i i was
holding it in i was trying to be nice
but anyway um so where does this fall
for you
in rankings do you hate the third like i
know you kind of talked but where is
this like overall for you i know you
said top boss like what are your top
three raids if you can put them in a
ranking right now what are your one two
three
i haven't done last wish a ton but i
would still say it's a better rate
overall if i'm just taking a raid as
mechanics dps checks like boss fights
you know like a little bit of everything
and a mix of everything like different
style dpss different style encounters
like i can't put val up there
with two mechanics out of a four
encounter read speaking
those audio waves later on are going to
be like bam bam bam bam bam bam bam she
preaches she's preaching go ahead girl
speak that truth like and and you run by
that like that's not a memorable
encounter that's not like a great
encounter like hey that was fun and it
was chaotic and you you know like every
encounter you get like hey that was
great i beat it you know it took us a
couple tries but
what you know what was the like the
great moment in that encounter like
i don't know it's it's lacking there for
me and and to you know yeah that k bar
shield just there you know what i mean
like
like we get he collects everything but
why specifically is that one there like
i haven't watched all the lore so i
don't know if it's explained you know in
some dialogue or something else in there
for that encounter yet but
um
i don't know
it's like like i said number one boss
fight not number one read though okay
fair fair so what was your other two
um raids
if you had the week now you know i would
still put last wish as number one even
like i'm not a huge fan of it
just like you know i've gone through it
you know and i've i've struggled through
it and i you know and i flew through it
with people and i've gotten a lot of
experience in running all the roles and
i just think it was you know unique and
different
i thought it was expansive too um
you know i'm not taking all the story
and lore and everything into it just
raids encounters mechanics
i would say last wish is still number
one
okay um
two and three
who's your two and three
two and three ah man i
it's it's hard because i really like the
taking king raid but i really dislike
the boss fight like
for the fulfilling factor like you don't
actually really kill him like you know
like where's the you know the we're
shooting him ourselves other than the
little last stand you know for really
quick for five seconds
but i i thought that raid you know that
was probably
that bolt the glass tied for my favorite
raid for a long time
yeah no fair enough fair enough
that's it well i just i had to know
well as it gets into raid debates we
always have a spiciness to it and i feel
like it got real interesting there for a
minute
uh nina sorry you got to see the the
bickering
bickering couples oh couple over here
we do that sometimes we all have our but
that's the whole point about like it is
it is
one of those things as you said best
boss
this again set up something for them
that that final boss encounter now has
truly that at least has set a bar at a
minimum yeah ever everyone who's
finished it has said that this is the
best boss they've done
so now and now this is why like you have
the savathon story and this expansion
going into one of the best boss fights
we've ever had
it is a very high bar just for the
encapsulated expansion so that's why
when travis said this like two hours ago
since it has been a long show
you are very hopeful for the future and
i think that is the best thing that
we've got we've got seasonal arizona
going on which has got some really cool
moments between salad and crow we've got
this stuff going on with the witness
where you can go in and learn more lore
about the about rock and the
civilization the pyramid ship
so much cool stuff is going on in this
world and i think it's just a very
exciting place
to finally be in destiny where you can
say how's the story was awesome campaign
how was the raid really cool
camp
crucible pvp gambit yeah that's that's
why it's an 8 and not a 10 and we get
that but it's like at this point those
certain cylinders are firing if over
this next year we can actually get some
work on crucible 2
yeah lightfall's going to be like just
absolutely outstanding they just they
have a high bar to reach at this point i
mean there's
you guys say like aesthetic amazing
music really cool the ambiance and
everything and then final boss like
maybe it's not hitting all the right
pieces for everybody but there's a lot
of things they did in there that really
did kind of you know you have your blown
away moments more so than i think i've
had in a while and it just feels
like we got to go to space
we did the
the gambit was better than taking king
that's hilarious
so disrespectful
i can't type because i wouldn't i'm like
i'm gonna call bungie on him because
they remember when he got the the of the
riff for doing the music for a last wish
the queen's walk i was like we're gonna
have to retract his reward for this slam
that he's doing for last question
continue
no but it's like i think that's
yeah that's what i was like pve 9 out of
10 pvp 1.2 out of 100 that's
one of the guys
i mean that's that's kind of weird i
even hear because i mean i got the
people i got to play with they are some
heavy pvp players and even like when
true vanguard's like i don't know if i
want to play that much pvp this season
it's like that's his thing that's
literally what he does so
that's why the at that's why you're like
8.9 is very generous for what we got but
there are some neglected moments and
that's why this whole year for me but
like just
expansion wise
i think this definitely wins
without it without
it's not even close
to certain encounters and things like
that we can squabble over those pieces
but yeah raid combined with expansion
and lore and world i think this one for
me just takes it pretty easily so
uh quick run through the twab i'm not
going to try and linger on anything
we're going to cover the stats
uh we do have trials if you are brave
enough to step into the invisible hunter
overshield devour world of everything
void 3.0 is going to be really spicy in
trousers now granted nina you have been
to the lighthouse many many times so was
it did i read that right like 300 when i
looked you up 300 somewhat more like you
are a lighthouse veteran is that well
did i find the right person on destiny
tracker let's just say that yeah yeah
okay good yeah i was i was not wrong
have you done much pvp and what is the
state of the sandbox for you in pvp
i haven't even done pvp for my pinnacles
honestly oh me neither
since which one came out
yeah yeah and i i literally like you
know when this game was in like kind of
like direness like back in year one like
you know after trials of the nine went
away and
you know the expansions like were kind
of
short and forgettable you know and
i played nothing but pvp in this game i
played nothing but comp in this game you
know when there was nothing else to do
preach
you know i i enjoy helping people to the
lighthouse on weekends like it's
it's always a fun feeling to jump in and
play pvp with whoever
and
i gotta say like
it's it's been tough with
less gunfights more space magic i guess
you know um
and to the point that it's you know it's
every
20 seconds 15 seconds it's like invis i
don't
like like and i'm a hunter main and it
it like upsets me to just like see what
others have become
like
yeah they are invisible everywhere
you're like is that dead
yeah like i don't know it's
it's not what i i took like pvp as a
game mode as you know to be all ability
spam or to use an ability to get a kill
every single time like yeah you used a
gun but you went invis like and then
crouched in a corner like i mean
like wow like i don't know like
like you're like wait wait way to do it
good job
yeah like
you won you killed him you're it's
effective i get it like it's very strong
but
it's uh it's been hard and you know i
play with a lot of pvp-minded friends
and
you know they also like to you know help
people in pvp and it's we're all kind of
like in the support group right now like
what what are we going to do
yeah that's us it's tough dude it's
tough
yeah
probably just going to play a lot less
destiny
to be honest
yeah right because pvp is what i mean i
know people like to crap on it and say
oh destiny's a pve first game and and
that sort of stuff but it's like the pvp
has kept destiny alive through droughts
that could never have been filled by pve
content just because it takes so long to
make it and uh i feel like uh bungie's
about to learn that
real real soon i think this year they're
going to learn that the importance of
that and hopefully i have faith i think
they'll turn around and change it i have
hope for the future as paul mccartney
once said
i will say i will say though like
having this sandbox of void 3.0 has me
really wonder
what they're gonna do with arc and solar
because right now we have like the words
you have like overshield and volatile
and invisibility and uh devour and those
types of things
we're gonna theoretically have like
burning and stuff i'm like right now my
shield
my barricade gives me a shield
i don't know what it's going to do in
the other two subclasses and it's kind
of exciting to think about that if they
do enemies go through it they'll
catch on fire maybe they'll finally die
as opposed to just almost die
because i cannot tell you how many times
people run through and they're almost
dead and still kill me with a shotgun or
whatever now it is really funny to have
somebody
run through and just like thump them in
the head and you get that really easy
like one hp kill those are fun remotes
to like pop the barrier just in time
they're like oh punch dead and i love
those moments but
i'm very curious because you've got you
know you've got your
your well making a little
arc guy what are they gonna do with
solar are you gonna have like a little
solar here that goes out and just like
spreads fire like i'm just
i'm very very intrigued to see what they
do with the other subclasses
and i think it's going to be a rough
year until we get all of the subclasses
at kind of the same
kind of outstanding level because void
is very powerful right now if they bring
the other two to that level granted it
does feel like we're gonna have
abilities everywhere all the time and a
lot but it does feel like those three
will kind of counter all around which
i'm very curious to see how they do that
i bet you flame is all about doing dps
so i bet you like it does feel like it
yeah the warlock well will do fire
damage to anybody standing in it and you
know the maybe the the shield as well
will do something like that like shoot a
wall of fire in front of it or something
like that i i could see them getting
real playful with it and it's it seems
just like
from what they did with void i have i'm
i'm like
pretty enthused i think they're gonna do
it because it seems like they're not
afraid to like add different status
effects and
make each of these corners of light
their own sort of like little mini
ecosystems that it's going to be really
tough for me to take off the overshield
because i'm just the ultimate survivable
titan right now like i can i can live
through anything i was like never dying
in the raid on contest mode like i was
taking out ads and people were just like
dude travis never dies and i was like
yeah because i always have an overshield
like it's not a problem so i'm really
excited to see what they do though what
are you excited the most nina for
sub classes that are coming in the
future is there one that you've like i
wonder if they're gonna do
anything for you that's
that sounds intriguing or like if you
kind of thought will they go this far
because they went pretty far with void
yeah you know i think they kind of
surpassed what i thought they would do
for the void uh update you know
much more options um
i do feel like the give and take you
know could be a little harder like you
know if you're gonna buff abilities then
you know
slow ability regen down or
um perhaps you know
dexterity or something else you know
with it um i know they've kind of done a
little bit of that balancing but i
i think that could play in really big um
i would say i'm excited for i used to be
a goldie main um
part of d1
so i you know i would love to see
golden gun kind of
shine again and not be like a like a
meme super a little bit um no for sure
nobody nobody's scared of a golden gun
whether it pops really unfortunately
um but yeah all the solar subclasses you
know um
they would be really interesting i know
they've
we've talked about what a
corrosion poison
whatever the next one is that's who
knows what that's going to do
yeah uh i kind of fear for that i don't
want to be like you know thorin status
all thorn all the time
you know flame is going to be damaged
over time so that means poison's just
going to make
all of your abilities take longer to
recharge for as long
it'll be like a suppress but like over
time
extra annoying and that with stasis
you'll just move faster your abilities
will be fat and slower your move slower
your ability to recharge slower
everything will just be slow it'll be
great yeah
i'm a big thorn fan though so i you know
i'm intrigued by that
because yeah like you're saying like
what else could they do different right
what would make it unique the one thing
that i did see and kind of give us
intrigue because somebody is saying
solar is going to have burning
probably also going to have healing
because it does now because you've got
obviously the void well and stuff like
that i'm like can you imagine the fact i
mean you've got sunspots that do a
little bit of that so they're kind of
dabbling with a little bit the one thing
that i saw was in season of the risen
when you're going through
the psyops battlegrounds and you pick up
the spear have you blinked with that
thing yet
no i have not
used go oh yeah really far and they said
in in yeah you can do it like bam bam
you can do it twice in a row and cover
massive chunk of the map
um
you can cover maybe not mass like not
the whole but you can cover a lot of
ground more than probably a normal blink
any kind of direction you generally want
to go
i've done it like sideways twice while
sitting there throwing it at her and i
think it was kevin giannis who said that
that's kind of the idea that they're
dabbling with for arc quickness movement
and things of that nature
so like that's another way that they
could take it as well so i'm going yeah
you might have an overshield hell yeah
they might be crazy fast though and i'm
like okay that's that that's the type of
stuff i'm like the game will not look
the same come lightfall and we're at a
point now we are leaning heavily into
void but over these next two seasons and
stuff and whatever happens in 19
no that's that's i think what i'm
excited about yeah trials this weekend
for the first time we got a scout rifle
aisha's embrace auto rifle which
summoner rifle's gonna yeah
yeah got rifle 260 so it's a rapid fire
um
triple tap and fourth time's the charm
theoretically get those i don't know if
we're going to be crafting any of the
trials weapons not sure if we're going
to be able to do that good question
about that oh true true iron banner
also
doesn't that get us a rework
no iron banner season 17 i'm sorry yeah
but we do have the new hand cannon which
i've seen is the goofiest looking hand
cannon in the game so far the sword
that's your lightsaber that everybody
was looking at looking at um that starts
on tuesday so no trials next weekend
trials this weekend break then trials
will be back
um
but yeah that's 12 is mostly just
like numbers and they've been busy and
you guys have been busy too so that's
most of it um we have kept nina for
quite a while i know we are coming up on
a good over two and a half hours so i do
want to thank you for
a lot of your time uh but at this point
as we do kind of wrap things up the
floor is yours at this point
if the people can find you for
wherever you like content for streaming
for anything that you've got going on
where they can find you what you do
um and all of that stuff at this point
the floor is yours to tell everybody
where they can find you
oh um yeah so uh
i just stream on twitch mostly weekends
because it was a lot of trial uh trials
helps
um
i do do uh occasionally the weekday
streams and we've been
doing a couple more now we're going to
be
uh having some more weekday streams with
some more raid teaching we've uh taken a
lot of people through the new raid
already and it's been fun teaching and
letting people practice
um i keep telling people you know now is
the time to do it because if you don't
learn
the roles and the mechanics and you know
try your hand at everything come a month
from now when people are tired of this
raid they're not gonna wanna make a way
do it go through yeah the you know the
leg work of teaching somebody so um
you know now
join up parades and you know just have
fun with it you know no pressure so um
but yeah that's really really just
twitch um you know i try to post on the
twitter a lot
and you know will take
a lot of suggestions from people that
you know
have uh struggled in raids or pvp before
you know
um
i try to stay really active and visit
you know hang out in everybody's streams
and you know i
try to
i guess uh make my rounds in everybody's
discords and you know you could probably
find me lurking in your stream a lot
and lurking in others you know and just
people that uh genuine people that you
know actually
enjoy this game and want to see it you
know progress in the right direction so
nice absolutely please go follow her
blow up her twitch twitter
do the right things hang out you know
lots of lots of support for our guests
so thank you very much for taking so
much time
as for travis and cog trav you got
something you can't quite talk about yet
right i can talk about it oh
yeah uh i will be reviewing uh
tiny tina's wonderlands the new
borderlands game uh i'm gonna start
playing it on monday and uh my review
will go live probably the day the game
comes out or the day before whenever
embargo is i have not checked
uh but yeah i'm gonna be uh playing that
over the next 10 days or however long it
is i have to review it um should be a
lot of fun you can find that on ign.com
you can also find my review of the witch
queen and all the other stuff that i do
uh and if you care at all about uh the
games industry i do a show on sunday
mornings uh called bitcast it's at 8 a.m
pacific and this last week i got into a
knock down drag out with mr richard
hogue himself
our resident lawyer on the panel uh he
and i had a very fun
uh debate slash disagreement on um
on the role of games as a service in the
industry and if it is a good thing or
not i was obviously on the side of yes
it is a good thing uh because i play
destiny and lots of other games and i
know more about it than him uh and he
was on the wrong side of history uh
obviously and so you can you can watch
that debate it's really awesome it's one
of my favorite episodes we've done uh so
please um tune in to that if you care at
all about that sort of stuff
um but yeah other than that uh thank you
so much for coming nina awesome content
creator uh the trials try hard we should
we should run together at some point
play some trials uh and [ __ ] what do you
got going on yeah
first of all salute to nina came through
so much fun just here so i just like
like well-roundedness as far as sd like
pretty much doing all components of it
rating because usually people fall in
pockets and you know i like when people
actually play all aspects of the game i
think that's really cool so salute to
you and salute to your good decision
making on raids
[Applause]
but all jokes
um yeah just catch me up our little
podcast every sunday
we will be back uh der griggity will
pull up so that should be fun and uh
peace also with everybody for supporting
uh defining duke we had it the episode
with mark dara from bioware it's now
free so people are not part of the
patreon you can go check it out on the
youtube on last a minute which is really
cool fun interview the guy is extremely
insightful and a lot of people don't
realize all the kind of mechanics and
sometimes why games fail and just the
size of teams it's just really
interesting
yeah very interesting man he was
forthcoming so i highly
highly advise people to to listen
especially your favorite games and and
he knows we used to do you know when
destiny was down we would do podcasts
like yo what's it gonna be that's i mean
division two anthem you know the killers
we recall right and you you hear about
one of the internal ones with anthem and
what was going on there salute that
asked with everybody in the chat
listening all foolish with the scarole
night coming through love it you know
everybody that pulled up iop clan dj all
y'all bla everybody it was a lot of fun
you guys make it fun and it's cool to
see everybody supporting and showing
love to eat and uh eman what's been
going on with you and what you got going
on me oh for me uh streaming
making content youtube uh streaming has
been a lot more recently
i'm trying to find my point where i can
balance destiny content so streaming on
a couple days and then find that point
where i can deep dive into elden ring
which will be my next one
uh but outside of that you have mostly
just like streaming i want to get to a
point where i'm really comfortable just
in all pieces of the raid so maybe help
some of the people on my discord with
that just to kind of experiment and go
through roles but
yeah i mean i really really am enjoying
the raid right now and just kind of what
it offers obviously of the crafting
weapons we want to go for so just a lot
of stuff in destiny in the cover but i
mean outside of me nina thank you very
much for again taking the time um you
have a great community because i know
half of them are in chat here just
giving you lots of love so it's awesome
to see when anybody else's community
comes over to
check you out on a different channel
chat with us chat with the community
that means you got a good group of
people over there so please anybody
listen to this find her last lady legend
is that right
lady yeah yeah i feel like i had the
words back first but last lady legend go
follow her go check out her streams
ultra nice ultra helpful very very great
creator
but that pretty much wraps it up this
one thanks for having me
our absolutely our pleasure um as we
wrap up this episode it has been
uh a really really good one i knew the
raid talk was going to be a lot it knows
going to be quite as argumentative but
we had a little bit of fun i'll had our
little spiciness in there but that's
kind of
tell us my favorite
favorite one
i think travis just looks to pick a
fight and then just see how much he can
like to poke the bear a lot of good
points brought up a lot yeah i mean
everybody's got their and it again a
different experience and stuff did you
have one error did you have six hours
like that's a different experience for a
lot of people so it is
it's gonna be a thing um but it was cool
to get a really good well-rounded show
and we had a hunter on tonight so he had
a nice balance which is always good
yeah so she is hunter at heart it seems
even if she dabbles hunter at heart for
sure so episode number 188 march 10th
post raid was a great one thank you chad
thank you everybody who hears this later
on if you do hear this and you made it
this far please drop us a like drop us a
review
send some love to this thing so you can
send it up to hopefully more ears and
help keep this thing growing but to
everybody out there for this episode as
we wrap it up it has been
last word